wait what it's one of the bishop wait
what just happened in this game to just
hang the bishop for no reason
[Music]
what just happened
[Music]
and we welcome everybody in on this
Father's Day with me here is of course
the the one and only Hikaru Nakamura who
is getting set to take on the the
world's most famous lizard at least as
far as the chess world is concerned
Hikaru you're joining us live from lobe
in Belgium where where you're in between
big events for the grand chest or but
how excited are you for today's match
versus the vs. of the dragon and the
odds matches so should be a lot of fun
well obviously the the odds matches are
kind of the big you know the thing that
everybody's waiting for for those of you
who don't know we're gonna start out
with a format where Ricardo takes on all
of the levels available to pretty much
every member on our site you can play
Komodo of all levels but then you build
up into this Monte Carlo version of
Komodo where similar to what we already
know happened when alpha zero hit the
streets back in November this is
supposed to be sort of a self-learning
self-taught approach to the game making
decisions not necessarily based on the
traditional evaluation that the computer
apply is like a math evaluation of
whether it thinks it's better but based
on whether or not it thinks a move
improves it's winning chances what are
your thoughts generally for the fans on
where computer chess is headed this
machine learning artificial intelligence
thing that's happening in chess where
computers aren't just helping evaluate
positions but actually teaching
themselves how to play the game and
maybe coming up with new and different
ways to approach it yeah I mean I think
it's certainly interesting when you have
computers playing where they're self
learning as opposed to with the opening
books I think they're much more creative
in terms of their approach and I think I
think in general if you're looking at it
scientifically there's a lot of upside
in terms of what we can learn from chess
but I don't think as humans will be able
to really implement it in in an actual
competitive game play so how closely did
you follow the alpha zero thing would
have jumped on the scene so you're not
necessarily convinced that just because
the computers are approaching in a new
way that it necessarily changes the way
that humans use computers to to prepare
for their own games yeah I mean I think
certainly for humans seeing the way that
alpha zero learn
in terms of its intuition the way that
it saw some binds are some some
positional pressure very deep in games
was very inspiring I think it kind of in
a way it meshes with what humans have
thought or the way we view attacks
specifically and so I think that's very
positive but I think in terms of trying
to apply that to actual games I don't
think you're gonna see that sort of
stuff mainly because most players these
days tend to steer away from the sorts
of openings that we saw in that match
okay interesting all right well I I'm
sure we could we consider and talk about
this the fans are really just here to
see you you know show Komodo who is who
his daddy is on father's day so we're
gonna let we're gonna have to do that
perhaps right at least for a little
while and as we build up into the higher
levels it's certainly gonna be exciting
to see what happens when the Monte Carlo
approach kicks in for a Komodo and and
maybe if that changes some of the
positions that would normally be very
tough for you right to play a komodo
rated north of 3300 Komodo or stockfish
or any of these super engines even an f7
pawn in odds and amove odds is not
normally enough for you to feel like
you're the better player is that fair to
say um probably not but I would think I
should have reasonable chances to
college okay what do you think is out of
the question but to draw I think there
probably or maybe I would say maybe 30%
chance okay
all right it'll be interesting and for
those who are wondering this is gonna be
the plan as you see on the on the screen
now we have Nakamura starting out
against computer level one on chess comm
building up to these odds you see we're
gonna end with the infamous nightmare
position that we haven't seen in machine
ods matches in a while excited to see
how the Monte Carlo approach the
self-taught approach of Komodo plays
against a karo in the nightmare but um
so reminding reminding everybody of what
they could do before we start Hikaru's
games just if you're ever curious how
you can play all of these engines on
chess calm this is all you have to do
right here is simply jump in and take on
the computers you'll find them under
play click on vers computer and you can
scroll down and and play all of the
matches that Hikaru is about to play
himself so without any further ado
baccaro I am just
gonna take a back seat here and we let
you do your thing
inform inform our team that that you're
ready to rock and roll
yes that I am yeah and okay remind the
fans that we're gonna take a break every
every probably five games a car and I
are gonna check in talked a little bit
about how the games have gone so far and
maybe ask a question that some of you
have I'm gonna be following the chat
both a twitch TV slash chess as well as
chest out comm TV shout out to our first
subscription of the day from distant
fire appreciate the support Ches Bay
gifting that to distant fire thank you
but Hikaru's here the car is here to
crush the crush the dragon and maybe
earn some more subs along the way so
Vacarro I let the team know let's do it
and the show the show is yours
sure alright well I guess yeah we
started the first game so alright son
playing 800 so this game should be
pretty routine I would think I'm not
expecting well there's a queen that's I
assume the computers in these games are
gonna play til mate so the first couple
of games should be pretty fast I would
think I would say someone in the chat I
think said it's 11:50 maybe on level one
but this is obviously quite a bit weaker
than that so see trying to mate as fast
as I can I guess first two games might
actually be a show and whether I
actually can see like meeting it's just
like meet and fives meet and threes or
something um okay well that's one okay
so now I assume I wait and it will start
the second game so okay so Game two
this this also probably won't be very
interesting in terms of the quality not
really expecting much okay well there's
a Czech needing one there so that's a
good thing okay so alright so that's two
down so I think the trick is gonna be at
what point is it actually fairly good
because at some point I might just play
like random first couple of moves and uh
and and then basically basically it'll
start playing good moves and I'll be
very confused as far as what's going on
so um do some d7 check maybe trust seven
probably King d8 alders trade take I'm
not
this game also is gonna be pretty fast I
would think so see what is be three free
rook I could take it but I'll just take
the pawn so well it's a threat and okay
so that's three down so so this is the
next one I think I'm still probably
going to play traditional moves for the
for the most part until I see it like
get to like move six remove something
without blundering anything and then
I'll know that it's game on but already
it's playing better it's it's already
only down one piece so let's see I'll
put b3 throw in a check try it probably
try and exchange pieces as much as I can
I'm gonna go for this just massive
exchange just no danger so this should
be pretty straightforward now try to
just meet as fast as I can and okay so
that's four so okay so pretty good so
far now it's already playing better
though already okay but it hung upon and
in the opening so let's see
Wow g5 bold East six Bishop b4 92 whoa
what what what is this takes just a free
rook it looks like so yeah so this
should also be pretty pretty routine
again now I'm just gonna simplify get
everything off the board not much
say about this game either so open up
some diag and checkmate in two yeah okay
so alright so that's five so I guess
well I thought were gonna be talking
after the first five games but I think
at this point you can just keep rolling
cuz I'm along with everybody else just a
little mesmerised at how quickly you're
beating it so we're just gonna wait for
you to when you feel you've had a game
that you want to talk a little bit about
where it's approach changed we could
jump in sure I mean it's already changed
it's already started to play on better
openings right you already played the
Moran and I'm gonna win this game but
already this is not this is it hasn't
blundered anything major yet so this is
a bit surprising and I think this is
probably gonna be the game where I
already I'm starting to get a little bit
worried about the position so this is
probably the game where it's gonna start
to change 7k7 king c7 completed b6 maybe
we should mm-hmm
see the Queen d3 rook e1 I mean already
I'm probably I'm still quite a bit
better in this game do this bad night
but this is not this is already not
trivial
shall we say finally goes there now I
think I can Chuck and now I just won
this one so shout out to all the subs
coming in I can hardly keep up with you
and you just baked kitty kitty hiss hiss
all right so it's gonna be a pretty
routine known as well okay okay so what
do we what do we think so far as you
roll into the next level I mean right
now there's just you abusing abusing a
weak dragon like a baby Komodo basically
yeah but I mean already its I can
already sort of start to sense it it's
playing much better so
this game I think I'm gonna also win but
it's I'm gonna win this because of an
attack and basically having to Bishop
versus or maybe it's gonna blunder a
piece action and then then it's kind of
irrelevant but I can already sense it
it's playing quite a bit better so I
might have eight how to finish it off
the Bishop d2 and now it's another one
so yeah I mean it's getting better and
better so I mean it's still I'm not
really having to try yet but I can feel
like it's it's getting to a point where
it's getting slightly close and actually
the other thing that's now that it's
improving I'm probably gonna actually
start trying to play real openings
because without the opening book it's
more likely to make mistakes right now
so without the opening book but if you
play mainline openings you're more
likely to challenge it in a theoretical
position that you know better yes okay
well let's keep rolling until level 10 I
think if we can sure and I'll take our
first break at level 10 sure now I know
it's doing us dubious but I don't
remember exactly Oh what is Queen f7
okay whoops it's a good thing I didn't
play 94 this might have become a real
challenge already it's about to like
mouse slipped that that would not have
been a good thing for 94 throwing a
Chuck try and do the usual work CD 2
doesn't matter I'll give up the night
for the pawn doesn't matter just breach
technically winning position and just
and okay okay so that's another
okay alright so that's another one down
so okay so far so good
oh but it's still gonna play the same
wine so actually there's gonna be
entering it's interesting to see if it
learned something just try to remember
how these lines go couldn't be five you
saw it I mean it's already playing much
better I'm now I have to actually focus
a little bit to win this one probably
try this rookie for or rookie to look
over key for see now this one I should
also win I've got rookie seven now mmm
clean house six are just out of five
probably take clay ninety-seven protect
everything maybe h4 trap the rook on g5
and okay it takes just take this one
okay it's okay so I'm gonna win this one
also
yeah it's quickest way to meet there we
go okay so that's another one so that's
nine up now though is it just gonna play
something every game is what I'm
starting to wonder is it just gonna keep
doing this until it actually finds the
correct line because we played this once
before so much.we 793 8 looks like a
free pawn it is a free pawn I think I'll
fish before you can take east six take
on
seven the g5 f e5 Knight g4 g seven
should be found nitrifiers takes okay
let's see 6h four a five play Bishop III
actually King h8 wow I can get away with
this
actually one 8.925 i think i wella now
if I take twenty six or ki five no
trucks
wait six will take pin the bishop force
g5 come back I can take this no bishop
moves I mean I can move his rook right
six maybe or queenie five queen six try
to simplify a bit although i know i
given Bishop f6 that was a bad move
because now no it's gonna get tricky
there should be five b3 bishop d4 i
don't really want to play b3 here okay
let's say so I play this should be
winning what work f7 oh that was not
expecting that one jinx jinx throwing
some chucks get everything back where I
wanted I don't know why it's not taking
this pawn but I'm gonna try to exchange
the rooks if I can that's that's my
first priority
okay now I will exchange them and now
it's technically winning now I can
slowly March the King up
play g3 throwing some chucks King 5v5 or
gate g6 now I can just run the a pawn
all the way up to board and it should be
takes
all right so it's 10:00 um yeah and it
ten ten games in a tent Oh lead so
doesn't doesn't seem like it it
challenged you much but toward the end
there right there was definitely some
technique that had to be applied
especially as you converted into that
rook ending is that fair yeah yeah I
mean this one also is pretty more or
less straight for I mean I think for me
the interesting thing is gonna be if it
keeps playing the Sicilian like this how
long until it plays one of the Kruk
lines basically because with the Monte
Carlo it'll be interesting to see how
many games it takes before it comes up
with the best line okay yeah that last
was that last one was not not trivial
again I think the thing is when you're
playing a computer you always start to
get hesitant like I feel like I missed a
few for sure I missed a couple easy ones
somewhere in there but when you're
playing computer you start to get a
little bit nervous you want to make sure
you don't miss any tactics and uh and so
that's why I think that one became a bit
of a challenge but so far it's so good
so some questions from the chat one of
the things that is happening here
obviously part of this feature is that
the computer has a basically a zero lag
in its move time essentially it's almost
pre moving every move against you
whether it knows your move or not is
that awkward to play against to have the
computer instantly responding to every
move or does that not faze you for your
your bullet skills anyway um it doesn't
really faze me at all I think of
anything it makes me happy because it
means that probably is playing bad moves
um so it's nice doesn't really affect me
at all right so I guess what you're
saying is as soon as the computer starts
thinking that's when you might be a
little bit and then you know you're
playing a stronger version of comodo
yeah pretty much
I think that would be my reference point
but again it's it's it's it's all it's
already starting to play better so I
mean you're gonna see that I'm not
winning every game as quickly and I'm
gonna start thinking more myself well
you're right that the first responding
to one of the twitch questions then upon
the first 20 games are not monte-carlo
it is the standard computer that anybody
can play on chess comm some of the
people are throwing out the adoption
emotes your if you're familiar with that
from your games with Eric Hanson right
didn't you recently adopt somebody on
before this Father's Day so you're a
father I should say garage you can
gratulations uh yeah I'm not I'm not
actually as far as I know but but at
least online I've adopted a few people I
think I adopted Eric twice right before
the US Championship so that's the last
person I adopted but I'll certainly be
back soon and all all trying adop's
notice how would that work in a
household where you have Eric Hanson and
now comodo alongside each other
obviously you just recently adopted
yourself a chess engine so explain to
the fans and twitch as they are very
proud of you for the Tenno suite that
you've started out well I mean I mean
commode is supposed to be a pet right
it's like it's like my pet dragon from
Chris what am i Hagrid or something I've
got this like pet dragon that I have
that's gonna grow too big and it's gonna
try and like you know like it you have
to protect Eric from it with fire or
something like I think having a pet
dragon be a lot more it'd be a lot
cooler than having having Eric living
with me yes yeah you know you can't talk
Canadian hockey with the lizard right I
mean that is true that is true that's
what I think lizard at least is not
gonna it's not gonna talk back to you
it's not there you're not going to build
on that sort of concept well for all
those of you who are on twitch right now
and perhaps this is one of the first
chess shows you've caught I believe we
are being rotated through the twitch
homepage welcome to our man versus
machine special here super Grandmaster
Hikaru Nakamura taking on the Komodo
dragon and we build up to stronger and
stronger levels as you can see above
mining hiccup me and Hikaru here he just
completed a Tenno sweep through the
first ten games shout out to all the
subs haven't had a chance to to give you
the love you deserve kitty-kitty hiss
hiss and chest BAE are gifting gifting
subs left and right we really appreciate
that
of course anybody who subscribes can use
the the Hikaru emote that we have here
at the twitch TV chess channel as he as
he rages on so it's alright so in this
last game hey Carl you had to use a
little bit of technique I was trying to
back up to a pollution before the chat
took me down the adoption route and one
of the things I wanted to talk about is
finding if I can find one of the
critical positions here where you said
you wanted to kind of play it safe right
when you when you played when you when
you head into the rook end
as your I'm on move 35 here you're
taking a dive and and trying are you are
you looking for whatever ways that you
can just simplify the position here
against a computer eliminate chances to
blunder get to a theoretically one
ending and is that an approach you're
gonna continue to repeat as the as the
engine gets stronger yeah I mean I think
if you can simplify simplifying is the
number one rule especially when you're
up material against the computer
anything that like when you're up upon
it's not the same thing but if you're up
a piece or anything along those lines
you always try to exchange pieces so
even though it's probably not I'm not
gonna be very precise it's the most
practical way of avoiding anything
creates right like I'll move thirty-nine
you go out of your way to play room
cheetah g4 you're trying to play Brooke
f4 make sure you get all the pieces off
the board and this is something that I
think lower rated players can even apply
to some of their own games where often
advantages are blown the longer they let
their opponent have chances and for you
against the computer you just want to
take away chances and convert on your
advantage in a technical manner right
yeah if I get to a position that's
technically winning I'm gonna try and
make it as simple as possible even if
course there are much easier ways and I
think generally um that could definitely
be applied to a game like this you have
to do stronger player with black and
weaker player with white where you'll
have to work to get to the seventh and
something crazy happens so um yeah I
mean in something like this where I know
that I can get to work in two pawns
against a rook that I know is
technically winning then I'll always try
and do that okay well I know that the
next game is gonna get set to start here
everybody as fans you buckle up here
hikaru will be will be playing game
eleven in in just a moment so within the
next few seconds expect that game to
start don't go anywhere all 2,000 of you
the the show was only just beginning and
the games are only getting tougher so
we're looking forward to that Hikaru
good luck in game 11 thank you
alright um now that I know it's getting
better I'm gonna start playing Jerry bad
shots now the anti anti computer trust
and it's doing its are already I can
play a four I don't know if it's good
enough to take yet shoot it is okay this
is not good no but it just plays off six
okay so it gives away the pawn on d4
bruh is it poisoned
there's Bishop c5 so okay let's see this
is not what I wanted so I'll play b4
okay thanks with the bishop which is a
mistake it sure taken with the knight
got three lies Bishop h5 so I'll play
brookie120 to lock it down now I've got
King eh oh not now again I'm reached a
winning position play a four plate if I
play off 5a and Queenie five so I've got
it that's the one thing that to be
careful but I'm just gonna try and again
lock up the position as best I can
well I give them Queen before so that
Queen a3 even though I've messed this up
no I know I'm gonna have to be really
really careful I play e5 it takes takes
rook a 558 it's almost certainly winning
okay I was sure it was winning but I
didn't see immediate knock up well this
has to be very very good if I just push
the palms up the board try to exchange
Queens and okay now it now is this is
winning again so let's no mistakes here
and it should be d5 takes east seven is
winning now employee seven and okay and
yeah now this is just over again so h4
it'll make sure not to allow any tricks
okay now I'll just just push the pawn up
the board and okay that's one more now I
know it's on f4 it took so I'm gonna
have to be a little bit more careful
okay Queenie sevens a weird move oops
oops that's a mistake just hung see -
okay still probably I'm still doing okay
in this game this is not ideal but it's
not horrendous I played d4
in b5 a 494 bf4 Queen before if I go d5
he's got Knight a5 Brooke c1 to threaten
Bishop c3 maybe also take a five
play it safely but now don't know when
as Queen takes Queen looks or a3 works
they both work
no no his queen is still trap so I'll
take take and now now I'm gonna try
again to simplify everything um what's
the simplest way I'll just take this
Queen b3 so not a meet here somehow
Knight a5 King be so clean b7 King a5
what so really no 92 95 King b6 I've got
9 c4 okay there really no mate let's see
Chuck takes rook c5 King before better
to be practical and make a stupid
mistake
take 94 gonna try to simplify as much as
I can now I'll try to exchange the rooks
she's 6 if I take G 63 g7 my bike we
know Chuck and okay
one more down all right getting tougher
slowly but surely so it keeps giving up
the [ __ ] ups I'm noticing it for some
reason it seems to like giving up the
bishop pair so you can i play d4 here I
could I could also take problems I don't
know how strong it is so it's hard to
play some of these moves without knowing
the strength it takes looks good but
maybe I can just wait I'm gonna wave try
try and do something the free pawn it
looks like Queen C 6f6 is begging to be
played
is this a stronger I know I got to do it
gotta go for glory so I'll take 93 Chuck
D for King each one so it wants to play
f5 Queen g5 Queen g6 Knight f6 looks
winning I can take the rook but I'll
take the piece piece has to be worth
more here so thank you - oh no did I
just blunder oh wait no takes I can o GF
5 GF 5 95 96 oh no did I just wonder
ok let's actually I have a ton of time
here so I can actually kind of chill out
- so let's take stakes 95 96 takes Riki
294 is technically winning oh it's got
f6 and 95 9 of 500 Wow
just take I'll take I'll take yeah and I
can check him to the h-file surely
there's got to be a checkmate here
somewhere okay well there there that's
that's good enough and okay no just not
to blunder anything and okay that's
another one and of course it's important
here to note that I don't style mitt
with Queen and Bishop against the king
like like a sprog did against your give
in st. John's maybe there's some blitz
tournament where he style mated giorgia
with a queen and a bishop against a king
okay that's one more okay so it's
playing much better this oh is this the
game where I'm gonna get crushed
is this a game where I'm gonna finally
get killed
Oh Bishop d7 that's a weird move now I'm
gonna go for the roll up on the King
side typical Kings Indian don't really
want to play off five but I'm up a pawn
so if he plays out five that I can just
go eat five and I shouldn't be too
concerned just bring my king back get
out of any danger
maybe a four to shut it down our teenage
- maybe I don't really like a four here
so let's see teenage to be five again
I've got to remember that I do have a
lot of time here so clicking h2o rook d8
that was not a move I was expecting then
go play up 595 maybe Bishop about four
hey Brooke I have to just protect
everything I really want to give up this
it's still weakened up so I feel like
somehow even if I lose a - there's got
to be a maid in here somewhere
so I take he'll take with a king play e5
maybe Queen h4 okay so now I eat he does
takes bishop g6 looks correct but if he
takes I check hang out seven takes King
e6 he runs if I take hold take with a
king or juice on Queen c2 rookie to this
age six is also possible here this
actually looks quite strong King g8 whoa
oh so basically it's just Chuck mated so
okay so that's another one down so it's
playing on I might go back to roll
opening in a second this is this is
slightly unnerving so what game so I
think it's still maybe master strength I
don't know what level it's at but it's
definitely playing a lot better so I
don't know it is if this was full
strength motor I would not play c4 even
though it's a good move from a human
perspective b5 and if I take Queen b6 a
4
I mean this position would be against
the human I would feel very good here
against Komodo I don't feel great and
that's Franck playing computer so if I
take work c6 Bishop e5 Queen d5 I could
just take us I could trade the rooks
take on our six and go work suit one
that should be good but I feel like I
should try and get better so that I
don't get tactically swindled rook c5
looks good or b8 so I can again he's
giving me the pawn maybe I should just
double Wow takes takes Bishop e5 rook c5
anyway new Queen c2 c4 okay so finally
he cracks and I take don't IV ie5 Knight
takes e5 play Queen see the Queen see 3
of 6 v e5 Knight D takes e5 rook do you
one queen e7 takes Knight takes e5
rookie 5 looks strong
ok so I play e5 he has to take one of
the Knights I think I'm clear do one
eyes got Queen g6 ok let's see there
should be 4 5
this has to be winning I take 9 f3
kingi to Knight age 49 through King a49
of 3 king of 294 okay now it's time to
just play simple truss and lock it down
um what's the best way take Rick Dees
queen 8 - King h8 rookie 5 maybe takes
d4 rookie a meat enough 8 now I'll take
mmm click Queen c2 Queen for Bishop g6
now Anna force an exchange again of
everything so it's another one down so
well yeah so we're
we well I'm so some of those games
seemed like they were getting a little
tougher right but how do you how do you
feel so the chat wants to know if you
feel like it's getting harder and one of
the things - it's good yeah I mean it's
getting harder the problem is and this
is gonna be a problem later right it's
gonna be a problem like the last game or
two is that like I'm still playing like
I think I'm better than the computer so
like I think I mentioned I played c4 for
example which I think in an or in a
normal game against any human I would do
it and I would be better against
computer I probably would not do it just
because it opens up the position more um
I think like in the last game or two
something Bad's gonna happen well um so
the rating of the guy while you were
talking I heard you speculating like
what how strong is the computer yet am i
playing a master level you see the
rating is actually right next to the
computer 15 if you look at your opponent
there it actually I didn't notice that
43 so but let's talk about that right
because maybe that's the the rating that
the computer has has gained by by its
performance against the average member
on our site but how do you feel the
strength is you feel like that's a true
reflection or you feel like maybe the
compositor thing is playing a little bit
better well it's it's still making one
to two big mistakes a game um but that's
about it so I mean it's it's hard to say
I think a normal human make a lot more
sort of minor mistakes consistently
whereas I feel like it's making like one
or two major mistakes a game and very
human mistakes so that would be the
difference all right but it's it's not
as simple it's not that's for sure let's
talk about that right cuz that's an
interesting query that we ask all the
time at chess comm right how do you make
computers play more like humans this is
an expert level computer quote unquote
but it does some things but you know as
you would say probably does something
stronger than an expert but then every
once in a while it just makes a random
blunder that may be a master or an
expert wouldn't play right and so how do
you feel that let's come back to this
position where you said c4 you talk
about this a little bit cuz this is a
move that clearly add some dynamic
features to the position you're prying
on d5 and trying to open up tactics but
as you said the computers gonna get
stronger and stronger to the point where
you may want to avoid moves like c4 that
add that sort of friction when you talk
about I need to be fair if I get a
position like this it's not gonna be
quite this setup I think actually even
computer I probably would still play see
for us it's a really good move okay
and so let's let's talk about how the
computer approach this so after D takes
e4 Knight takes e4 Brook a six at what
point do you feel like the computer
makes a move that is weaker than its
level say we'll call this you know 2100
well okay six is a weird move for
example I think any human would play
rook e8 not work a6 okay their exam and
then I think yeah II four also is not a
human move here either I think you know
from playing bananas or bancos all those
sorts of setups where you some a3 a5 we
were playing for b4 you'll never seen a
four like in the game allowing allowing
basically what you want with b4 is what
happened right exactly yeah yeah so I
mean I just would not expect that really
okay and that's unusual certainly then
this approach with Knight takes and
Queen takes talk about this moment here
where you were you were calculating the
move f4 and I think again if I'm fair to
say that the Hakkar nakamura that I
would watch play blitz and bullet and
adopt Eric Hanson might play a move like
f4 right your clean up or instantly
right but against the computer so what
is it about the position by the way
member G 0 DX and the twitch app wants
to know if the adoption papers with
Hanson have been signed yet no all right
so they haven't been finalized no no
guys now I was chatting with Eric this
morning I should have told him he was
gonna be the punchline during today's
show he would have loved that so distant
fire actually what we have you and this
break wants to know when you're planning
on streaming to your own personal twitch
channel again what your plans are
sometime after the Paris Grantchester
event so I'm guessing around the July
1st would be my target goal somewhere
right around there
okay maybe not exactly at first but if I
had to guess if you if you put a gun to
my head and asked me to pick a date I
probably would say July 2nd that would
be my guess okay so plan on it and for
those of you who didn't even know that
hit karo has his own channel you should
go there right now and follow him and
maybe even subscribe to him you've all
he's not streaming twitch.tv /gm hikaru
but okay so back to this position talk
about that I think for the fans as far
as what you're evaluating about f4 that
you love and would normally want those
types of tactics but in a game like this
you chose
sort of a more disciplined rook c5 which
is very straightforward you're gonna
double rooks on the C file and and and
keep the tension as is well I mean I
think that's the other thing that makes
it hard playing computers you're much
more careful than you normally would be
so like against the human eye I would
play a four probably instantly the
against computer I mean even though it's
supposed to be 2,000 already you're
you're trying to keep it as simple as
you can and not not allow any tactics
now here are four also is a great move
I'm sure but I just don't want to allow
anything weird to happen possibly okay
all right so you played rook c5 and the
computer almost seemed excuse me I
accidentally jumped to the anything the
computer almost seemed like it was it
was playing gonna be gonna be playing a
solid defensive approach here sorry I
lost the I lost the mood that's all yeah
he plays rook to b8 to prepare to double
on or double on a on a rank which is odd
on the B file but after Queen c2 it
became clear the computers couldn't hold
and and then II for and and you started
kind of cleaning up here so computer
2050 not quite a human 2050 but doing
some things well right now making you a
little worried some things not as well
as you expect it to do in a few games
yeah but I mean I I'm expecting game 19
or 20 you're gonna see me slow down a
lot I I expect that to happen
well we've asked a car with some of the
questions shoutout to all the fans and
thank you for thank you for all your
questions in the chat trying to keep
track of both chess TV and twitch.tv /
chess they're both pretty active we're
gonna let it Caro take a 30 second
mental break here as we as we get set
for game v 16 to start the fans have
been asking when do in the chat when do
I anticipate based on what I know about
the comodo engine for it to get hard and
I said I think about level 16 is when it
seems to be tactically strong enough
that if you made a human blunder it
might actually catch it and really
punish you right do you do you feel like
it's getting close to to that level not
not quite okay okay good I'm glad
okay well and Larry Kaufman I can tell
you off the record told us that he
didn't think you would really have a
challenge until level 19 or 20 so that
was that was
and Larry obviously has has spent spent
a decent amount of time with with
computers in his life so yeah okay but
we're gonna take a quick 30 second break
everybody don't go anywhere and the the
next games between Hikaru and and Komodo
will be will be starting in just a
moment
[Music]
all right oh it's no I do not go off to
smoke under OPC but um yeah so
yeah question came in what hakuro does
on the breaks I'm gonna guess he takes a
swig of redbull and doesn't go for a
cigarette but that's just me yeah that's
not me I don't smoke sorry
smoking is bad for your health well
playing playing hey Cara so far has been
bad for for Komodos health we'll see how
he holds up here is game game 16 level
16 gets underway here in just a moment
everybody if you do want to follow the
games yourself you can also go to chest
comm slash live and just follow the
games directly in the live server and
shout there as well so I'm still trying
to figure out it's hard for me to figure
out whether I should play the hippo or
not I think I'm just gonna stick with it
for now OHP 494 tree but I don't go h3
it would go Queen f6 and I actually just
beat me right on a spot now again it's
still giving up the still giving up the
bishops which is interesting
ticks queen g5 I'll click Queen off to
develop oh did he hang an exchange her
97 where's the knockout blow
mmm it's so much it's still not super
strong so I'm gonna keep playing active
chess I can take the pawn I can go
Bishop c1 lot of attractive options here
um um what makes the most sense let's
see it takes takes is you have Knight a5
or something Knight a5 Queen f2 click
Queen up I play Queen h5 to force an
endgame I mean that feels really wrong
but if the goal is to win every game ah
let's see
so Queen h5 take 6 95 94 93 96 94
night--if 893 97 night f1
probably winning nights a little bit
mmm okay I've got a lot of time let's
see 25 takes two is 95 94 93 96 94 9f8
93 I'm at the brook he is 92 Chuck if I
play 97 night off one King up one f6c
for King off 7 c5 pawn gets a c6 that
should be winning but that's not trivial
um I'll just go back there by v g3 they
should eat six Wow was not expecting
that
um g5 so I cake cake rookie six rook up
to work age 62 bishop c6 rookie a rookie
7 work c1 king of shirk see too busy to
work f2 huh take six
work after work age 62 Bishop c6 Rocca
feet rook to e7 Roxy one king check but
you to work off - and I've gotten
nothing so I don't want to do that I can
take and play Queen e2 95 rookie 694
work age six
so it's 93 yeah not simple okay but if I
don't take I don't really have a whole
lot Queen to Knight a5 rookies 694
chicks turkey shoot work f2 that's not
obvious either if I ta takes
3 9 to 5 I don't want to play G Forex
and he's got night h4 can also play work
f1 maybe now I can play g4 and I get
some kind of end game that should be
winning should be winning but not
obvious maybe c3 then he goes she 4
takes work a 4 7 she Forsch be
see-through Queen c3 g4 is winning so
now I'm gonna force an and again this is
this is actually what I was hoping for
when I played c3 now he wants Knight d5
Knight c3 so I'll play a four draw draw
no draw why is the computer offering me
a draw something am I missing something
I can take with the pawn DC 5 b5
this has to be winning surely a v e4 d
6r
six actually keno Keaney 597 anyway yeah
should be winning but okay let's see um
whoopsie for take with the c-pawn maybe
I can see five track yes and there we go
any stopping a knots game no Queen takes
gee if I would be cellmate here by the
way just so alright that's another one
okay that was not easy so now I have got
to be careful again and it gives up the
uh-oh
spaghetti oh maybe that was wrong I take
Queen h4 King f-106 wait is that 5f5 who
me just moves the knight okay and like
Knight b6 or something 95 94 I also have
c3 maybe c3 takes takes it's a big pond
that I just got on d4 if I play d5 95
what's he threatening nothing sides up
with King g1 take a five or defy if I
take d5 he's got Queen h6 so I should
take okay now I just have to make sure I
don't blonde or anything or f1 when you
6.90 for play d4 I can also take mom how
to exchange pieces here let's see so
I'll just no Queen up to g5 maybe d4
just get my king safe now go for the
kill your d6 maybe okay now I get Queens
off the board so this it's got a lot of
pawns here but the the two rooks and the
two bishops are much too strong York b5
got it Chuck put the King in the Box
here and now I'll go for the takes or
I've got shot ah King c7 okay and here
we go I know I just exchanged on the two
bishops er gonna roll the day important
not to allow the bishop to get trapped
so that's another one so okay three more
to go
and so now
gonna play what is it trying to do rook
c8 that's a weird move castle I must
it's interesting as always giving up the
bishops which is interesting
so a 500 played d5 I didn't think it was
gonna actually break up the center like
that like Queen c2 control efore 95
maybe a rookie maybe just wreck a do you
wanna keep it simple
95 f5 might be sex ok
32 p4 is a move I don't really want to
play b4 I'll play Knight c3 this would
be 7 picks been exchanged by lose h3
Knight B 5 is maybe night b5 knight c6
takes Knight a7 maybe fire ok night b5
as a move which would be sevens move
King eh - maybe mm-hmm
mm-hmm I'll play prophylactic 94 maybe
94f 596 rook c7 f6 okay d4 maybe now
I've got 96 + b5 possibly come here just
96 right away and now f4 b5 night before
to be very careful here it's queen for a
night before Queen before no tricks
but Queenie a four-night DBA maybe b5
night before Queen b3 night c5 takes
Bishop d6 BC 694 Queen a 492 Bishop g 55
so Queen may be Queen a for Queen b3
Queen b3 c5 commuter has to be right 95
takes Bishop d6 BC 694 yeah for what
does EF okay so take takes 94 Queen a
493 bishop d5 queen air for
- Bishop d5 Knight f3 King G - no tricks
or Queen b6 maybe Queen B actually
couldn't be 692 55 maybe 692 Bishop d5
takes takes Knight C for Queen b5 takes
takes winning not odd so Sun below
Bishop takes e4 Bishop before takes King
g7 now it's just bad couldn't be three
is no good so Queen here for Queen b5
Queen b6 before takes T eyes got 94
maybe queen c48 rookie 192 Aaron our key
190 Toyotas c5 Wow hmm this has gotten
tricky it's gotten very tricky from out
of nowhere so there should be five maybe
90 - Queen d2 ring rook e1 was
legitimately a bad bad move c7 or CSUN
queenie for okie so this rough six
Knight f6 or p6 should be
how easy is that some FG v 9h [ __ ]
Jew - okay or Queen D Queen D for work
e6 Queen C for 2498 maybe five
this has to be winning somehow template
Queen d7 no not quite maybe no G for is
gonna close the position down so maybe
maybe a shorn tanks d6 if I take it's
not good I'm gonna let it set up some
kind of ridiculous fortress maybe three
for Bishop now I've got Queen d7 Bishop
d6 anyway twenty-eight King f8 f6 takes
King to five Bishop c7
seven
this has to be winning somehow why is it
still putting up so much resistance bump
up upon a six takes King King e7 no I've
got oh wait no I have sex he still takes
Queen Jerusalem King me six Queen gee
Chuck King before King b5 maybe King b5
what's he hat which we it's rich Chuck
King d8 f6 Knight f6 clean off 7-6 king
of six Queen e8 f 6 king he sucks takes
rook e7 go yes
wait Dorothy Oh Chuck he nice Chuck
Chuck King e6 Queen off 8 King e6 Queen
g6 or g7
chapter
oh how do I miss play this
you can use her accessory unfortunately
this is now a draw I think kini for
Queen each anguish
wait what it's just one of the bishop
wait what just happened in this game
dude just hang the bishop for no reason
what just happened in this last game I
was confused we're headed for a draw and
it just blundered the what just happened
there that was really weird weird enough
I think to take an early break because
that was fascinating I think that it was
it was hard for me to stay quiet I know
what you're thinking I I'm impressing
you today by my ability to not talk
right can we admit that yeah yeah I was
confused I mean the computer just lose
its mind or something yeah so the fans
were going nuts here I don't know where
to begin with this one let's let's talk
I guess about this last position here
because comodo after defending probably
better than any human would defend this
against you right I mean that's super
difficult to defend this I mean I don't
think it's actually difficult to find I
think you just see the bishop on f6 and
go over a key five work g5 um so back to
this position did you did you have some
sort of awkward mating net that um I
don't I mean I just maybe wait to root
well yeah actually I just realized yeah
after a rookie one Queen d3 the bishop
gets
crafts I think suddenly I didn't even
see it at the time I was trying to move
quickly but actually yeah it actually it
works because the bishop can't move
anywhere except be for AFI without
giving allowing a queen D to attract
everybody that's the idea here is the
bishop suddenly blundered itself if it
moves off this diagonal White has this
fork on on d2 so right if you go rook c1
you law queen III Chuck right and if you
go rookie v King d6
then Bishop a1 there's got to be some
way to pick up a bishop there I'm
guessing or action a rookie v the move
might be king see wait no Kingston for
Bishop a1 King D since Bishop a1 there's
got to be a way to pick up the bishop
here maybe Queen d1 Queen d1 yeah cuz
I'm Bishop b2 Queen d2 of Bishops III
Queen c1 I forgive my queen d2 yeah
that's it
okay so no no Queen D one cuz Queen B
one maybe they're still Bishop d4
okay so Queen to d1 and the bishop has
run out of squares everybody if the
bishop goes to be two this would have
been the magic square c3 Queen 2 c1
and if rook a5 as a Caro said Queen to
d2 check what's the move or what was the
move on rook a 5 yeah there should be
two Queen Queen d2 Bishop c3 Queen C 1
or K 5 Queen d2 or we know then there's
rook c5 wait a second yeah I was looking
at rock a rock a 5 rook g5
although there was there is some may be
awkward idea that you check on d2 Roachy
fiving and bring the king closer maybe I
don't know
ah maybe that works yeah it's Brooke g5
King e6 the bishop has to guard f6 or
it's over
yeah Trust is too hard it's fascinating
when you're playing the computer and it
clearly saw something that that you you
know even as a super GM human didn't
quite see yet and then all the sudden it
plays King g5 and just gives you the
bishop right I mean and then you were
shocked and and the twitchchat went
crazy so how does let's back up even
earlier because I think the most
instructive part of this game is that
you clearly outplayed the computer from
start to finish as you have been all day
you buy all play the computer the first
35 moves and then it out claim me for
the last I guess from start to finish
from yeah from about Bishop d5 you win
the Queen here and you know it seems
like we're on our road for due to a
technical victory now after 94 where did
you feel you maybe lost the threat or
perhaps underestimated that there was a
better blockade here for black than you
first thought um I mean I think probably
somewhere around this which which
position you know I think somewhere
around move on yeah somewhere around
this position I think after b5 I just I
didn't realize how hard it was to
convert this because as I mentioned
where during the game I was analyzed in
Queen Cakes b6 and I would have just
gotten a better much better version of
this I think that been in the game with
Queen a4 but yeah I think after after g5
was all it was pretty pretty tricky um
and I suspect it was still winning
somewhere around the time of move 44
probably f5 was a bad move I mean it's
probably winning but it's just it makes
it a lot harder if you're not super
precise so after you took f6 you played
rookie six seems like the conversion was
was on and you're saying perhaps f5
wasn't maybe I mean I could have also
take have taken g5 maybe okay I mean
maybe not Queen d4 probably take g5
right well but then 98 is it's tricky
it's it's very tricky well I admit after
f5 and then black was able to get you
know sort of a surprising blockade on
the dark squares have reminded me of a
blunder that you know very well that I
made against your brother a much much
worse game than anything and you did
hear you remember the game I'm talking
about
I never saw that game I think I mean I
don't remember exactly how you got
forked but then at the Nationals game
were a where I was unable to
I know it's I know it's you know I'm
comparing a game that is nothing close
but all of a sudden it was just
surprising that despite all of your
entry points black just black just
doesn't have to do anything here but
just sit with the bishop and the knight
on the darker is right so do you feel
that was already a draw even though you
eventually did swindle the night away or
or was it or was there just I think it's
probably winning technically but it's
just it's too hard when you've gone from
winning pretty routinely to having made
a total mess of it and especially
against the computer which makes it
makes matters worse that I suspect is
still winning but I mean I thought f6
was good with them it had this trick to
just give up tonight and then it's
definitely a draw I think that was
surprising to most of us as we're
falling the game because I thought that
once you had sort of wiggled the Queen
around to have the threat of f7
obviously because ff6 isn't a threat
while you're queens on h8 because Queen
g7 he can just take you can just take
the e6 pawn right exactly I thought that
once you had achieved this this position
where you did get f6 that it was winning
and but you're saying then probably
that's actually just not a win it's
already five maybe there's a way to win
but it's actually maybe Queen of five
actually Queen of five might just be
winning server c6 and I'm east 7 and
which in which position Queen a 5 move
69
okay so Queen a five instead of Queen
takes g5 yeah but even Queen a5 rookie 7
it's still not easy but I think that's
probably winning Queen a5 rookie 7 kings
c4 should be winning the king is sort of
frozen here right if it takes c6 the
bishop falls if you moves the bishop you
get Queen d5 check so maybe right if you
take the con there c7 aha c7 overloads
the king everybody can't guard c7 and
the rook there ok interesting so that's
probably winning yeah instead of Queen
g5
got it ok well it's super instructive
here obviously just to see the computer
defend after going down thanks oh no no
cuz Queen up five there might even be
Bishop f4 again it's it's it's not
obvious and anyway it's definitely not
obvious
do you think computers defend these
these unbalanced I mean in a practicum a
practical perspective I don't think any
human defends a position where you have
a queen and you're poking and prodding
at all these potential tactics and
weaknesses but do you think computers
defend those unbalanced material
positions with I mean if there's no
fortress and yes the humans are gonna
find fortresses better than computers if
it's not a table base I'm game but if
there isn't if there isn't like a set
fortress then then no certainly
computers will defend much much better
okay Wow I don't always understand
fortresses either I will say so
sometimes you you can get away with that
too okay
and that's plague it's like ten pieces
or something there's some kind of you
know fortress a computer might not
completely understand and is that sort
of like The Horizon effect we talk about
where humans can sort of see quickly the
big picture of the forest through the
trees where computers have to calculate
is that kind of what you're talking
about computers are just may not
understand that they have a fortress and
so they they change the position
unnecessarily I mean I meant more if you
have it as a human where you're on the
wrong side of it but I mean I think
computers gonna probably find those
moves anyway but it might not actually
play the repeating moves though in
Western other oxys okay all right well
we've still got a lot of people that and
many people saying that they're hungry
they want they want to go get a meal
hikaru but they can't walk away because
that game it had everybody on the edge
of their seat we we know that you had
some ramen right before is that brain
food gonna help you here for the last
few games hopefully I mean this game was
unpleasantly high difficult considering
the great position I got out of the
opening so it's probably gonna get worse
well I mean honestly I think this is as
well as humans have felt against against
the you know that are artificially
intelligent enemies in a long time I
think I think this is going well and I
honestly with the approach of Mountie
Carlo being different in those positions
you've played before do you think your
experience in these types of matches
really helps you knowing what type of
position to choose against the computer
I mean you you hope you just kind of
pray and hope and if it works it works
but most the time it's not gonna work so
you kind of just hope well chatting with
the chatting with the twitch chat I was
saying that I think you've probably
played more of these
of man versus machine cyborg matches
than maybe any of your of your top ten
in the world peers is that fair to say
yeah that stuff that's definitely fair
at least that I can think of right I
mean I feel like we've got it for sure I
played in four games against computers
than anyone else but I don't think
that's nice that's necessarily a good
thing or it means in some way that
because of that I'm better than anybody
else it's just something that I used to
do a lot of okay well all right we're
gonna we're gonna have another 30-second
break we are getting everything set in
regards to preparing the Monte Carlo
tech you have two more levels against
straight up Komodo regular chess
thinking before we see how the Monte
Carlo tree search changes Komodos
evaluations so we're gonna take a
30-second break everybody Hikaru's gonna
gonna do what he does in the in the next
30 seconds and we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
sure that's fine
[Music]
[Music]
you
all right so what's this game 19 two
more to go so it's still playing bad
still playing weird moves now it's
trying to improve so it stopped me from
castling
so I'm guess I'll play this one I could
play f4 here I'd let's see how do I want
to do this click Queen d2 play work d1
Queen a1 maybe
d4 a plea for so I'm gonna try to
shuffle a little bit here get my king
over to each two if I can um now I'm in
trouble so now I've got to go for
without 4x Knight b6 maybe Knight f3 or
f5 not fives to loosening okay Queenie 7
which I forgot I've got so much time
here I really can slow it down so create
one see fine I could take on d4 maybe
okay now so it miss played it so now I'm
just uh clean pawns so this again has
turned into something much better than
what I had even a few moves ago so I'll
play f1 or Ricky one I think I'll play
rook F 1 now what am I missing here I
have five ones a piece I think maybe I'm
missing five what Bishop c4 Bishop d5
what so as if I
Keeks it'll take and hope for some some
horse trick so I'm gonna play King H one
night see fort Wow it's weirder okay so
now I've got to just take the piece now
he five is a move how do I simplify this
action maybe simplifications are wrong
with looking at it already because good
enough now that probably I can't
simplify quite in the same way so 92
appears to pick up the bishop which
would be a good thing
Queen g8 I don't know what that actually
does so I could take I complete Bishop
c3 all sorts of play Bishop c3 so now
it's just kind of repeating so Knight f3
Bishop f2 is a problem so I could just
take maybe okay I've got five minutes
plenty of time no need to make a mess
out of this game so it takes create 93 I
don't know what that does we'll just
play e5 maybe six f6 has to be winning
but um f6g f6 Knight a5 rookie six I
still it has to be winning somehow so
okay so takes maybe Knight be three
rookie six
okay so Knight be three rook d1 Bishop
f6 King g8 or a few one or a few six
nights ah yeah this is 93 rookie six
wait 9 p3 rookie six or da takes takes
Queen takes 95 Queen a 193 Knight see
206 maybe walk
and if I take tank tags going off seven
bishops III should be winning yes okay
now ivory she winning again good all
right
okay one to go one to go her what was
that
what am i doing
okay so Bush base wait no takes bisa
okay sovereign king c5 now I think I've
got fish base six and now I can just
exchange hunt and kill one more to go
one more I'm being told that uh that
maybe the fans want to review that one
real quick although I think fast nating
about that is that fair to say that that
was just much easier than level 18 why
was that oh because it lost the thread
in the middle basically like I I was
much worse probably somewhere around
moved 25 or so I feel like I was in a
lot of trouble
oh no you had played f4 what what about
this position makes you feel like you're
you're in trouble well I mean the thing
is night night night be 698 force coming
right away okay and somehow I felt after
f40 X takes maybe a block I could have
just played Knight b6 right away um and
after Knight f3 I just somehow felt like
there should be some tactics in the
position for black I'm not really sure
where but I just had a feeling that
there were tactics here like I'm not I
don't have anything specific in mind
maybe even just like Queen h5 after G
takes off for with the idea of 94 93 it
just it feels a little bit loose somehow
but maybe the computer just calculating
better than me maybe it already sees
there something wrong and well I mean
the thing is the way it played it just
went passive and so because it went
passive once I picked with a deep on it
was just it had no counter play so you
played you after might be six you played
Knight a free and like you said it plays
the move Queen e7 rather than a more
aggressive idea like a queen h5 perhaps
and and well but it now it's too late
already because now there's Knight g3
you have to do it tonight on detail
so perhaps then you reach for where it's
here you don't know Queen h4 moves so
queen h5 instead of might be 6 if 93 or
Queen h4 and they're still rocking for
check coming I see ok mm-hmm
so the what was interesting is is we're
all we're all watching this happen and
you know after the last game you sort of
expect it to only get tougher you know
you won this really long grind-it-out
endgame and here the computer you know
walks right into into a position you
played Queen a1 to defend your pawn d4
falls and the rest was was a matter of
technique so is it I don't know I guess
it's just hard to figure out why the
computer plays better in certain
positions than others and one thing I'm
curious about is you have level 21 more
to go are you gonna play the hippo again
is this something you feel as effective
right now or is it something you're
stuck I still it it's effective it used
to be effective even against computers
when they were at their at their
absolute best um it's still probably as
effective I think I'll leave it up to
the stands I'll let them I'll see like
ah since I do I was at which window open
I mean I'm gonna let people decide you
guys tell me if you want to see e4 you
want us to play the hippo again so well
sorted out with some evil advice for
those who may have joined late Hikaru
was playing some efore we had
consistently a Rhossili most Sicilian
for whatever reason was Komodos choice
but then then you've you've been pretty
now we know the hippo works against Eric
Hanson and other and other human
grandmasters what is it about this sort
of sacrifice of the center the double
fee and keto approach that you think is
effective against the computers is it is
it you know we know computers have a
tendency to sometimes overestimate space
what what if I walk the position usually
they'll play to lock it up with d44 okay
usually the structure if it gets closed
you can kind of try and play some kind
of Kings Indian type attack and I think
in general you really want to get that
sort of a structure against the computer
if you can get a Kings Indian generally
speaking where you got four or five g4
okay then you then you definitely get to
play have you got some chances to attack
that's really the only way you can be
computers these days so it works
true to your words after you play Queen
a1 the computer voluntarily plays d4
right it tries to grind close the
structure you were
with e4 and then eventually you know
mobilizer playing with a four you just
made a comment that the few ways you can
still be computers is in an attacking
type of position is that because you you
get them in position where maybe they by
chance underestimate a sacrifice or
something like that or what why why do
you why do you say that sorry can you
repeat that again I think you might
comment just now that one of the few
positions you can still beat computers
in or positions where you're attacking
the king why is that
yeah well it's because the computer
doesn't have a horizon so if you can get
some kind of king's any type of attack
it doesn't really see the main ideas
coming until usually it's too late so
that's generally what you want of course
most time you almost never get that
operating cuz because computers are just
far too strong to play those opening
setups to begin with so it almost never
happens now but if you can get that then
you always have some hope okay
fascinating stuff I feel like these are
just like you're under estimating what a
protip that is and that's because you've
played so many games against a computer
but I think I think that's fascinating
because obviously like you said there is
still the very few horizon effects that
exist for computers are probably around
sacrifices or long mating sequences
where they just think they're a material
but a human season mating that idea down
the road right and so yeah exactly
okay all right well we've got level 20
right up and then we have Monte Carlo so
everybody who's here you're laughing
they're obviously probably probably
enjoying the chat here shout out to
everybody by the way who we haven't had
a lot of time to say kitty kitty hisses
Ches Bay just gamertag we really
appreciate all the subs remind everybody
if you didn't know this you can
subscribe with your Amazon Prime so if
you're not using your Amazon Prime
subscription please consider doing so
and activate your Amazon Prime alright
DiCaro level 20 yeah you're right
your last straight-up battle with Komodo
until Monte Carlo takes over I think
we're ready all right now it's thinking
okay so this is a bad sign apparently
what I said was prophetic in a way I
apparently knew that it was going to
start thinking as soon as we reach this
level
so okay so now this is gonna be
interesting so it's still thinking um
what is it thinking about okay so it's
it's going to one of these deep like one
minute tanks there should be six I'll
play d3 make sure there's no e for right
away
[Music]
so what is it thinking about here
castles will play 90 to try to prevent
efore at all costs if I can
ninety-two also I'm gonna move pretty
quickly here trying got get up on the
clock so I figure there's going to be a
situation later in the game where time
is gonna matter Queen d7 I'll play h3
kick the bishop make the premium of it
almost certainly won't take but I'll
still make the pre move
so still thinking a lot here a 597 maybe
were Kea those those would be the top
three that I respect age six is not
really what I would expect here I could
play b4 I don't think I'll do it on c4
not not at this level so I'm gonna try
to run with my king to h2 here I
couldn't castle because nh3 would be
hanging da King g1
he's six I could play kh2 maybe I don't
know if he's gonna play h5 or not that's
why I was hesitant to play this but all
I'm just gonna move fast here try and
move fast get some time on the clock so
that when there's a critical moment I
can use two to three minutes in fact it
does play h5 which I was not expecting
now I play Knight f3 e4 Knight g5 h4 is
not an issue okay I'll just retreat with
King G one see what it wants
obviously quite a bit worse in this game
well that's like two games it's clearly
figured out how to play against the
system so I'm glad this is last one
regardless of the results I wouldn't
want to okay now it's gonna know it's
going to be hard
[Music]
ninety-seven tryi four or maybe Knight
c3 Knight f3 allows knight c6 but I've
got 95 there maybe although it's really
thinking a long time here so I'm gonna
play 95 maybe I'll take the product all
back if I take he can take and then the
F file is open so I don't really know if
that's actually a threat or if I'm just
pretending
but I still think I'm relatively okay
here so 97 that's annoying now I take it
takes ah night h7 that's annoying move
that is a very annoying move no no I
guess I gotta take and pray now so I'll
take all pre move Knight c3 probably c6
e for pretty ugly position and most
likely I'm gonna get crushed this game
so we'll see but this does not look good
okay I'm gonna play E for on giving up
the F for square because I figure if he
gets an f5 I can just resign so we'll
see if I can somehow survive this this
really doesn't look very good though
Bishop c5 okay that's an interesting
move not really what I was expecting
actually so like Queen e1 promise
hopefully Queen e1 there's not now
Knight f4 but she takes chief or as a
threat to but Queen if I don't go Queen
e1 I'm in a lot of trouble now so maybe
Queen f1 ooh this is ugly
on the
oops I am way up on the clock though so
if I can get the computer just think a
little bit more maybe I can pull it off
somehow but I see I'm still not very
optimistic about this
so 92 he'll take probably so I don't
want to play 92 but I don't really have
many good moves here I always try to run
keen eh - or maybe we rookie one hangs a
three-night a fortnight's going the
wrong way
tit taking on d5 terrible I can see it
off five this is ugly
hmm this is not pretty at all so I'm
gonna have to just kind of wait and try
to move fast and hope that somehow I can
trick it trick the beast goes Bishop d4
play rugby one maybe Queen c5 eyyy eyyy
I have four and now I'm in trouble
definitely in trouble now it's trying to
take maybe I can play a form pray or th2
maybe
it's getting awfully low on time this
game I must say King g8 wow that's a
weird move okay now hopefully work off
one to talk to talk
do seven okay hmm
still very very ugly for me maybe a four
and try to hold somehow it's five okay
that's because I took away that square
from aya a night on a forum maybe there
should a one maybe I mean I guess he
wants Bishop III in 93 tricks
six click move got my bishop out of the
way
uh okay now I have problems cuz I'm kind
of stuck Playworks c1 maybe
b4 is very ugly I'm really just running
out it moves this game problem is now I
can also play B 5 B 4 and then C 2 is
really weak also they should be 1 maybe
oh I'm so ugly 92 92 bishop a one night
of four kings takes Queen c2 it's just
pawn play Roxy well Brooke c1 doesn't
actually do anything that's the problem
rook c1 b5 takes takes there's no actual
threat I mean
[Music]
hmm maybe for Queen c4 a5 Bishop a7 will
or maybe Queen d2 there's no actual
discovery but just b5 anyway and before
okay so it goes 'if I've so 92 maybe no
92 does nothing it should be too hangs
be 3-play uh-huh
no no this is just terribly ugly and now
I'm getting a long time so I'm just
gonna probably crack and lose pretty
soon always is 0.3 and
I just wondered before I just couldn't
hold it long enough Merc say no I just
gotta move fast and hope but I think
it's a all kind of gone for me at this
point you should be too but no I've got
night off for maybe 25
teenage 7um rhetoric a three or with you
guys got rooked III now and I'm just
busted cook like a goose
oh yeah and that's that's it yeah all
right that was a very unpleasant last
game
well the question is can we fairly blame
the twitch chat for this for telling you
to play the hippo one more time maybe
you're in not really I think the
computer is already at a point where
it's it's not 2449 that that I will say
yeah it's not playing at 24 49
it's already playing quite a bit better
than that
so I know I mean I got a bad position
but no I just I mean that's what happens
when you play against computers well
some some of your supporters were
blaming those who voted for the hippo
who wanted e4 so I don't think the hippo
is the reason I lost I think I would
have lost no matter what I did well you
know so it was obviously still a very
successful result I mean if we look at
the overall you know score of how you
played here given the opportunities that
there are to blunder against a computer
you got 19 out of 20 with comodo getting
one victory right at the end but as you
transition now into what is gonna be
totally different right we're not gonna
be seeing the hip on the board here
we're gonna be seeing odds positions for
those who who don't know the odds
positions actually let me bring them up
for you right now so that we can be
reminded of of what hit karo is about to
to do taking on the the Monte Carlo tree
search system which again the best way
to describe it is computers gonna be
making decisions based on wind
probability and sort of self-taught a
self-taught approach to how he he
maintains those those win probabilities
but we start out with a pawn and two
moves you get the white pieces how do
you how do you evaluate what what you'd
like to do in the in this first game
it's just gonna be an uphill battle
okay there's not much also needs to be
said and is that it's just it's just
impossible when you're playing somebody
that's strong despite the the odds
advantage it's to to predict how this is
I think I think the odds of the odds of
winning are very I mean I think
basically you have to decide whether
you're gonna be practical or not you're
gonna be practical and try to play
solidly and avoid losing I think it's
very very likely that you won't lose but
if you try to win then you're almost
certainly gonna lose so it's not a
matter what your approach catch-22 I
guess I'm playing a strong engine like
this alright well we're transitioning
now into the final stage of the match
today want to thank all three
thousand-plus of you that are currently
here and those who've been here if you
just showed up shame on you for missing
the first 20 games but any any final
thoughts on how that last game we know
was tough and the computer certainly
just had a very very strong almost
strangling approach where I just didn't
allow you to get much where do you think
maybe the if there was one takeaway for
yourself and this in this last game
against level 20 that maybe you could
have done differently I mean I could
have played a different opening I guess
you could say but um but yeah I mean in
in general it didn't make any mistakes
so it's already at a point where even
though they say it's 2449 I mean I think
that's questionable I I think that's
obviously I've never seen the computers
on our live server play as someone of
your strength so I agree with you this
question I would have put it more at 27
or 28 49 to be honest definitely
stronger than that but somebody did just
give this up to a user named hippo on
Twitch for your efforts so maybe at
least at least we got that out of it the
hippo lives and is currently a
subscriber to our Channel alright
everybody we're gonna give a car a break
to go freshen up because this is when
the gloves are really coming off Komodo
sort of unleashed so to speak the chains
come off we do handicap it with some
odds but Hikaru will be taking on an
engine rated about 3300 Plus which I
think is I think is appropriate given
that we currently have thirty three
hundred and sixty-four viewers on Twitch
semi car will go ahead and take a minute
break and we will we will come back and
start the Monte Carlo tree search battle
here in just a moment
sure okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay here we go
hey Carl you feeling ready yeah Komodo
Monte Carlo tree search engine game on
man vs. machine good luck uh Carl thanks
alright okay so I presume I should try
and take the center that seems like the
most obvious thing to do and so now I
can check and grab a second pond Chuck
g6 Quincy 596 Queen c3 e5 Queen c4
Knight f6 v d5 what a c5 what is c5 okay
I'm gonna go for it and I might lose
this game really badly in like five
moves or something if if I'm not careful
yes actually I've got ten minutes so I'm
like the past games I can also think
quite a bit more so II 6 click Queen C 3
Queen d2 maybe Queen C 3 nights this 22
Bishop h6 okay Queenie v 9 f 6 doesn't
look very 25 9 since Bishop g5 Queen you
find nonsense between a 496 c3
okay I'm gonna go for it if you please
Knight f6 hopefully queen of four
right six no no place c3 or e5 c3 looks
correct just two because I really want
to play e5 95 Queen ops 3 and prevent
him from castling on the off file
although if I might have been stronger
just eat fine 95 Queenie for Bishop e7
c3 because now he might be able plate d6
an e5 or something
and sure enough he does go d6 obviously
hmm let's say okay so Queen h4 Bishop e7
so continue developing
that was very stupid I mean I should
have played it five right away it's a
bad decision play Queen h4 maybe or just
develop a nun Queen age for me
d3 e5 is that a threat
not really to move not really that's
right
the Queen h4 trade exchange
come on let's trade the Queens it's a
good decision trade the Queens come on
fish
g5 of course darn it doesn't want to
exchange the Queen's
okay so we push we three I could play
night eight three maybe actually
threatening to take on d4 so I could do
something immediately about that first
of all 93-95 Queen b8
g4 is always a move I don't really want
to play it but
I really don't want to play g4 here but
it's Oh what else to do
councils e5 Knight f4 is very serious
right
she for 9:06 queen g3 95 97
I know night before night before is also
a threat here to is the night before on
top of
so g4 night before gh 193 King e2 looks
okay
or Queen c4 c4 Knight f6 Bishop g5
castles night PD to e5 okay you guys I'm
gonna go for the win
okay Knight f6 Bishop g5 94
castles maybe DQ looks fine
let's see what his next move is here
for those of you guys can switch you say
yellow or something pretty much in this
game I'm trying to win this game so if I
if I lose the game it's because I'm
trying to win because I feel like
there's really little point in trying to
be stable
there's nothing major on the line in
this match so I'm definitely gonna try
and win the scheme and it most likely
will backfire but I feel like it's the
right thing to do so II five I expected
this tell him to play d5 take on he
can't do anything funny here with chief
four so he's gonna move the knight now I
think I'll play just H three as long as
there are no tricks like 97-95
e 4 or something I should be able to
stabilize the position right da don't
play H 3 protect the pawns and so here
everything is stable if I can get like
two more moves like Bishop e3 and
castles Queen side or Kings side or even
Bishop e3 Queen g3 if I can get some
sort of stability I should be doing very
well here but I guess maybe
beast looks night be some night see five
darn why does it keep finding these
moves it's always some stupid
compensation of the computer has in
these positions very annoying
there should be three night be seven
maybe Bishop h6 9p some tanks King g7
hmm how to play this position castles
Nikes on rookie 195 gypsy - fine I will
just castle a5 that's not what it looks
[ __ ] okay so a five so I'll play rook
e1
a four
okay see one of a three I just could be
three
my complete [ __ ] aged six here maybe I
don't know if I want to on 95 but
actually why not
95 and just Bishop be one and try to be
try to keep on saying Saul but I'm also
exchanging some pieces now and also with
a knight here there isn't some Knight up
seven tempo on the Queen here I should
be one oh no - zero sack coming here on
g4 now oh no does he have a sack on g4
no maybe not I've got Queen h3 yeah
takes takes 94 Queen h3 I'm okay still
so now I'm trying to sack on g4 so I
think here I don't have to get super
passive maybe I'll just for true but
then he's got h5 maybe so I guess I'll
play Knight h2 so I mean I am winning
here I think I'm up to clean pawns been
able to exchange a set of bishops it's
not great but it's not terrible if I can
just get this night maybe two like g3 or
something I should be winning it's
easier said than done obviously cuz all
my pawns are misplaced here uh-oh
I did not see that one Oh No so works
see 293 c4 Queen c5 and I woke up one
that looks pretty terrible in a queen e3
queen me to Knight c4 wait but maybe it
so take 94 then queen up - is it - right
so takes Knights work one takes nine
three four so how to defend night oh
[Music]
okay let's see it I'll play Queen III h5
o f3 maybe try to stay solid here
thanks I'll take with the H want I guess
I feel like I'm hanging on by a thread
here somehow a little bit concerned
mirror cakes on rock h7 I just need
somehow to find a way to exchange oh wow
Queen d7 so basically komodo is
admitting that it has nothing here more
or less so I want to play b4 yeah I feel
like I need to play principal chess and
try to beat the beat the stupid thing so
b4 make sense
so b5 likely be for here don't know if I
want to but it feels right so let's
let's go for let's kick the knife from
this annoying square and so not really
what I need to do here somehow I need to
figure out so night 86 Wow okay so now
I'm definitely doing very well I've got
a great position this is definitely
winning it I guess any human I would win
this position so I've got what I want
but whether I can convert this is a
whole nother story now I'd really like
this night to be like on eat or g3
actually maybe even night be 395 knight
c6 is also possible so it's trying to do
something here on the kingside I think
I'm I've got to be careful that I don't
allow some sacks on d5 because King g2
Bishop d7 with Bishop takes d5 Knight f4
is a problem so I might just play rook
a1 I think I will I'm gonna play rook e1
put some pressure here so goes rook b8
so I could play King g2 this would be 7
I mean it's very clear that it really
wants to like sac somehow on d5 so I
don't know if this idea is the right
idea but it feels like a reasonable
concept
so okay so he's gonna try to sack so I'm
gonna play broke a7 try to force some
exchanges of pieces down here if I can
and probably is gonna go work b7 I would
assume here yeah no I'll take I'm gonna
play rook okay one try to force more
exchanges I mean it's obviously gonna
take I don't know why it's thinking here
that's very strange actually but if it
takes me maybe go Queen a7 actually
Queen a7 Bishop c8 when I seven Bishop
c8 Knight a5 nucleus seven Queen hey
some Bishop a6 or something okay fine
I'll stick with my original idea play
croquet 107
you
though so does sack okay so it's sacks
but I figured I had to have be okay here
g5 9 age 5 CD v 9 up for bish buff 1
chief I tanks 9 of 494 maybe hmm there
could be three GF 6 row 694 or calf for
Queen b6 rebuff 7 we've got Queen g5
here maybe it's still so close to winter
now Queen g5 allows Knight f4 so I've
got a retreat
I can play Bush
efore Queen b6 Queen f2 and that looks I
mean I'm gonna
that's gonna force some kind of end game
maybe that's got to be winning Shirley
but maybe it's not so easy actually
because queen bee sucks queen up to TX
TX Knight c3 Bishop c6 just 95 it's not
as easy as I thought it was actually so
takes takes Knight c3 Bishop c6
95 back I almost certainly can't lose
this but whether I can win this is it's
I thought I was just winning but or I
look at this so I'm gonna end up losing
both these two pawns it's gonna be very
hard to win this so now he's gonna go
Knight d5 this is gonna be hard to win
I'm not sure I can win this see if I can
as expected so now I have to trade tags
don't have to take the night maybe mind
if one night before it's gonna be hard
night if one night before Bishop d7 I'll
go for it why not
hopefully I don't get my Bishop trap
somehow here on c6
so d5 some King III makes sons came
through D for King D - it still has to
be winning for white I would think but
my nights are very very clumsy here so I
can throw on a Chuck maybe if I want to
because he's gonna go King he wants to
go King b7 king c7 there's trout my
fishing I could go king D - I guess
yeah and he's gonna go back so I was
gonna make me have to throw in another
Chuck that I don't want to so he's gonna
go a nice III Trek or night III Wow okay
that was slightly unexpected so shocked
she needy sucks no and played g5 I guess
if I want to I think I will open open
some squares open some create some some
air for this Bishop it's a 93 King you -
he wants to go night off for play 21
so I really would like to get this
Knight to e2 if I can somehow I'm gonna
try and do that now maybe
oh wow King c7 oh geez I'm almost
getting this bishop trapped again this
is crazy
92 92 93 back okay so guess I can repeat
if I want 92 would walk into a very
funny checkmate so I'm not gonna do that
maybe Knight c3 Knight e2 back maybe no
he also opened the a6 diagonal to so
teeny one oh wait now he's gonna repeat
[Music]
- King C - D for maybe d4 Knight c14
Knight G 3 maybe yeah d4 93 d3 King
Suwon looks good
thank you 6 Bob Bishop a six-night h3
stupid stupid computer so annoying
no no I can't win this game but
eyebright I'm gonna end up making a draw
I think hopefully I make a draw I
wouldn't say it's guaranteed that I'll
make a draw on this one but no ifs for
he's gonna go 94 of course the coins the
draw I just want to see that would take
it or not it's gonna take obviously I'll
play 94 blue this one I should've won
this game should have won this game
now wait King b3 allows 95 so that would
be a very poor error in judgement thing
now I'm just going to repeat what
94 now if I go can be 3 yeah I know I'm
just gonna make a draw you guys that was
a very disappointing
very disappointing game should have won
this one definitely should have won this
game so now I take he takes on d4 so I
just have to exercise a touch of caution
here but I think wait if I take 92 wait
maybe this isn't as simple as I thought
it was one second
96 king D 6 night of 4g5 king before 92
wish me to g5 night h3
maybe just 94 kills it 94 95 king before
92 Bushby - yeah
this should kill it assuming I don't
blunder anything obvious here this'll
make a draw stakes came out for I think
97 97 is good enough to make a draw -
mmm terrible now if I take teenie to
night a for is a draw
95 king before 92 King before it's all
draw not good
so yeah anyway next game Errol is it not
gonna take a draw here or something
that's going to do something weird okay
this is
it's silly now but I'll just chase the
night off all over the board
indeed a little silly but as you as you
chase the night let's let's analyze this
a little bit I've got two boards up for
the fans so I know I'm asking you to do
two things at once but you know you're
you're a really strong grandmaster so I
know you can do it so where do you feel
the thread the thread slipped I'm back
to move 25 where you played before and
as you said yourself you need to play
principal chess and beat this new thing
which by the way is one of the best
chess quotes of all time play principal
chess and beat the stupid thing but
after you played before it really feels
like you were in control for the next
set of moves thinking thinking it's
definitely I was definitely winning I
was happy with B for I was happy with
everything probably up until rookie a
seven maybe I mean maybe I had something
something better than that
they finally finally taken the draw so
I'll switch over here to the main board
I mean it was definitely winning I'm
pretty sure probably somewhere yeah
somewhere around moves 33 34 probably I
had something better than what I did so
let's let's uh this these are obviously
the most important ones so let's um I'm
gonna I'm gonna bring up the game in
analysis mode and actually invite you to
the board so you're about to get an
invite mm-hmm to the to the board there
yeah so now you can just run the show
and move all the pieces as you yeah I
mean somewhere around here it had to be
winning um
which which move I mean much much much
later so like somewhere around here I
mean or what's going on are you are you
on the main board I invited you to let
me know I think so yeah a whole bunch of
people just joined it so you know I mean
well go in I guess I'll make the moves
then you can see I'm on move 35 he takes
d5 mm I didn't see that but anyway yeah
okay so you played comp or i'ma move one
actually right I don't know why we're
not synced if you're if we're analyzing
a different board here but okay yeah I
mean I thought somewhere I'm Lu 35 I
mean move 35 I've got you know Bishop
takes d5 you take with the pawn clearly
he's getting some compensation for the
pea
but it feels like why should still be
winning here yeah I mean something I
don't know maybe maybe I'm probably just
Queenie for yeah just Queenie for
instead of Queen Queen uh D - D - yeah I
probably Queenie for I didn't realize a
g6 was hanging yeah Queenie for would
have been winning I think okay
yeah Queenie for is easily winning
actually Queenie for Knight f4 bish buff
one just completely winning um Queenie
for night at for Bishop f1 keeping the
pieces on the board
no that's easily winning them in yeah
okay well I mean maybe it's some queen
e7 Queen h4 tricks but I mean that
definitely is is very very good for
white okay so yeah that's that's where I
missed it was not going Queenie for that
was a mistake
and and poorly that you're you're maybe
I don't know I'm thinking about Queenie
for Queenie sixes man I mean it's still
not so simple okay his Queen for Queen
there all kinds of tricks Knight c3
Knight f6 there's also like rook a4 may
be right it's not it's I mean it's
definitely winning but it's not not
trivial right and you know earlier in
the game you were I mean it was it was
very impressive if we were back to even
before you played before when you found
this defensive resource - Queen b5 which
kind of surprised you obviously he
brings the Queen to the Queen side hits
the b2 pawn but she recognized the trick
on Queen III that he can't just go
forward and take me - and once you sort
of defended that tactic with this with
this move Queen III did you really feel
like like you said Queen to d7 was a
sign that the computer just didn't have
a clear plan yeah I mean I thought that
was the the main point I mean I was very
happy I found this key for me because I
think in the opening I would have won
this game very easily if I got me five
instead of c3 I'll move six yeah I think
that was a very big mistake on my part
and why is that that line you gave where
you said e five night moves and you're
able to prevent castle well I just grow
nut I just go Queenie form basically
black never gets played d65
uh-huh Black's very passive and you
can't develop the light square bishop
along the c8 f5 diagonal okay I remind
you I got a great position anyway
because I I played this G formal which
as I think probably very good but very
hard to play against a computer
ya know you spent a lot of time on that
move and it was so after after c3 you
were you were really really thinking
about whether or not you wanted to take
that a sort of risky approach but it
seems that you don't let the computer
affect a lot of how you evaluate in
approach these positions is that fair to
say that that's something you try to
work on and continue to play I mean the
general evaluation no but I mean I think
the main thing is you always you always
have the ceiling you're gonna blunder
somewhere I think it's the you that you
won't blunder on and as you saw in the
game I did blunder I mean I played Queen
e2 which I thought was great cuz I was
getting into an endgame the only problem
is that the 4 was falling in that in the
in the end right but yeah I mean I still
think yeah III I don't think it affected
me that much as you always are like
double checking to make sure you aren't
blundering something right ok so as you
as you launch the I'm going through the
game after a5 and now moving forward the
computer found this b6 97 I c5 idea but
like you said you defended well and
really feels like you were using your
advantage in this odds game like you
said up until up until Queen to d2 ok
now you probably also moved 34 maybe I
could have played c4 that also would
have maybe made more sense c4 to
overprotect d5 and kind of prevent yeah
I got probably take stakes and it's
probably winning I mean I think it's
very strong at least ok the extra be
pawn and I guess in this case makes it a
little harder for black to open up
things with a sacrifice on d5 mmhmm
right yeah well amazing I think at this
point you're you're finding ways to
criticize your own play but the truth is
it took stellar defense by the computer
and probably just this one in accuracy
of Queen d2 for it to hold and now that
you've had a feel for playing the Monte
Carlo system and you're about to take it
on again again to remind everybody the
the Monte Carlo tree search is is what
that little red dice between the lizard
represents there Vacarro just played
pawn and to move odds is about to play
Knight 4 pawn which according to the the
co-founder and the one of the big brains
behind Komodo is is very close to the
knight to the to the f7 pawn and two
moves
what do you feel your strategy would be
overall in this no I mean I think having
a piece is much better than having
better odds yeah for sure okay so you
feel excited about your chances now to
have the night for the pawn if I play
anywhere near as well as I did last game
I better win this one all right all
right well we're excited to see it we're
gonna take one quick break give you 30
seconds to refresh and then we're gonna
start things off and game number two
Hikaru versus Komodo monte-carlo we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
okay so I've got a night on f7 um let's
see probably e5 is bad because of Bishop
c4 so I assume I'll play you six just
cut the diet diagonal off or wrong way
but okay so I can play g6 maybe or maybe
c5 just try and force something in the
center d5 also maybe d5 make sounds good
a five then I'll just play like ninety
seven knight c6 try and play some sort
of winter war but I just need to make
sure I don't get like steamrolled with
the up in the e pawn to d5 seems like a
good move
85 I was not expecting that it's all
take I've already gotten a very nice
position again I must say because now
that now this f-pawn does there are no
real ways to attack like he really
wanted to get like something with f4 f5
rough 4 e 5 and prevent my development
but now I'm just gonna be able to go
Knight f6 Bishop d6 and castles and I'm
looking very good so far also it's gonna
be hard for what you get a setup where
he doesn't exchange pieces here so let's
see so now I can play Bishop d6 maybe
this position I'm very happy with this
is a very good position very good
starting position as long as there are
no tricks here at the start some like
9595 stuff so I can get Knight f6 and
castles I should I should win this game
I think
please c6 I don't have to
yeah but why not let's play c6 keep it
simple so I can take and go night e7 I
can or yeah I can take and go 97 and
knight c6 and it's very nice as Borat
would say very nice so umm Bishop d3 I
don't even know why I just did that I'll
play I'll play I'll play 97
maybe I'll go 97 Knight f6 possibly okay
you guys
reading your your comments in the chat
um so he castles all Castle basically I
really want to get in some Bishop f5 if
I can if I can get Bishop a5 in then
I'll probably just be winning almost if
I can get some exchange of the light
square bishop only thing White has here
is this one diagonal here's why I assume
hopefully Queen c2 here but you never
know cuz the computer also with the odds
and sure enough it does play Queen c2
why am I not shocked so I'll play CH you
know I'll play h6
and so basically want to go 1979 f6 by
kion or even DC for movies so he plays
c5 to lock it up but on the flip side by
locking it up now on I've also got b6
bish basics to exchange too and it's
hard for white to create any sort of
attack your although my knight on e7 is
a little bit a little bit misplaced so
yeah I plays rook e1 I'm not surprised
um
now I do have a slight problem here I'm
noticing he's got some weird night eh
for Bishop h7 work takes seven tricks
which could be a problem maybe I'll play
rook e8 first so now people he's 1984 I
have the brilliant Knight f5 and if rook
e8 Queenie ain't Knight f5 I can play
Bishop a5 and if takes I've got Chuck
made on the back so you can't go knight
eh for now and so now I want to go 97
and maybe Knight f8 96 something like
this so okay Bishop d2 play 97 and yeah
I want to go night f8 and Bishop g4
maybe or night f8 96 something along
these lines but I just want to get this
Knight to f8 and then I'll worry about
this this night on Esau because it is a
touch misplaced and maybe even Knight f6
Knight Knight e4 makes sense - so I go
night f8 he's probably going to play
rookie -
I'm gonna play defense here then I play
maximum defund so I'm going with King eh
eh at night g8 tried exchange in pieces
so rookie three no actual threats all
displayed Bishop d7 protect everything
and I'm just going to go King AJ on IG a
very simple to move plan
h8 once it's worth noting night h4 I can
still play night GX and night on f8
coverage c6 and h7 so basically it's
Komodos going to be hard-pressed here to
avoid a rook exchange now I can't change
even one set of rooks the task becomes a
lot easier to h3l
she ate and already I'm very happy now
I'm very very happy with what has
happened because all my nights are
pretty reasonably placed I'm going to be
able to change a set of rooks and this
is this is looking up 92 not an actual
threat I don't think so i can play
Bishop d7 if Knight f4 I'm just Oh a
knight have for Queen on six he's got
nine th five I missed that that's a
slight problem maybe 904 I can even just
take and play Queen ah six rook e8
so he just gonna up for ya I mean I kind
of thought I'd you know 6g through
rookie 8 and I solved all my problems
but I overlooked this Knight h5 move now
a real man here will play g5 I don't
think I can play g5 here I mean I don't
really want to take either but so if I
don't take what are the other options 95
95 h g5 create a weakness not a big one
five bishop eh hmm
Knight f6 is also possible here was on
don't really do much and I just looks 95
mm Queen b8 maybe my age 5 Quincy and
food
695 takes 694 tanks
mr. pond Queen b89 age five maybe just
something simple a five nah maybe 95 is
a threat now a 595 bush p5d 95 mmm
or the bad option
you
the food
get time try and play it safe so takes
Queen f6 Bishop moves anarchy 8 that's
my plan
especially five
takes I'll take this eh protect protect
everything at all costs I really want to
go 97 now if I can Queen b3 there's no
actual threat wait is he a bishop a6 now
I'll play a six I had work eight
probably I could make it draw but I
don't want to make a draw it is one
piece after all
Oh bishop see - oh shoot that's annoying
that is very annoying Queen III oh
that's really annoying
okay still
one piece though we need Swart we three
Knight f6
23 so we want to play a four I guess
ah okay I'll play Knight f6 I guess
protect everything about for I'm
probably gonna try and chocolate 94 to
loosen the light and the pressure
oh did I just wonder 27 I've got Queen
on something okay no Kuni some
about Bishop d7 on some way gotta be
careful be careful be careful here
[Music]
[Music]
completely bungle this completely must
miss played this still probably better
but now this is going to be very hard to
play against a computer changed
interesting this king is true do exactly
ninety eight rookies seven queen of six
for an ID seven maybe ninety seven
ninety five takes by faking
ninety-four
the Sun if I wanna [ __ ] jittering g8
you
probably this is losing somehow but I
have to go for it running out of time
[Music]
clean three we worked the eighth Mimi no
the night age four so he's threatening
night age four I think or no he's not
out now he's for Queen age five 9f5
[Music]
yeah I've got no time which does not
help the situation at all
I need for Queen h5g three no threat
now okay fine enough just just play
chess play chess work be seven and
Queenie for us I'm gonna I'm gonna go
for it and hopefully I can somehow draw
this probably I can't draw this but
maybe I can same position right yeah
I don't see anything better you guys
some it takes a draw take the draw great
if it doesn't it doesn't
wow I'm surprised are you surprised -
computer take a draw
um yeah I'm actually very surprised it
took a draw but I guess it thought um I
guess it thought it wasn't better in the
Sun game after work xb7 Queenie 4 I mean
it looks very scary to human but so in
this position instead of queen of four
rook takes be seven Queenie for how do
you evaluate the end game here well I
mean the thing is white goes like rook a
seven and maybe it's good for black
somehow but I mean with 30 seconds on
the clock I'd be very very worried about
playing this is black yeah it just looks
very good to me optically right
and obviously the just like you said the
time pressure is a big part of that
right because you're you're always one
move away is a human against a computer
one moves away from blundering okay well
yeah but I mean that's yeah you're
always you're always right there so no I
mean I was so happy with this opening I
mean it's how did I mess us up yeah I
feel the same way if we back up to this
maybe maybe I should just play Bishop a5
I'll move for maybe that was the way to
continue that makes more sense
Bishop f5 makes a lot more sense and the
reason is you're just are you gonna try
to put the bishop on e4 and just sort of
well I'm just gonna develop normally I
mean the problem in the whole game is
that I ended up in this position where
like where he had this Bishop on d3 I
mean it's still a piece but the bishop
on d3 was the one shining light in
White's position and I could never
really I thought I would somehow be able
to exchange on f5 and I just couldn't um
yeah I missed off five would have a much
much better yeah yeah that's - yeah you
you never really had
chance to exchange off everything again
so Bishop f5 would have been your choice
next time yeah for sure and I mean even
later somehow maybe instead of a this
Bishop d7 idea I should have played
Bishop e6 and Queen d7 that's the other
thing that I probably could have done
okay oh my god I just still don't know I
mean bees I move 13 Bishop e6 rookie one
rookie one Queen d7 I mean the problem
though is Bishop a5 and Knight a5 or not
actually a threat to be fair right
like if white just plays I don't know g3
or something I mean I mean g3 is a bad
move probably like rookie 2 if white
sits tightly pointed there's no option
of really putting a piece on a5 because
of the tactics on EI at some point
although yeah this would have been much
better actress bish b6 yeah okay well I
mean it it felt like at a certain point
you almost would have wished to have had
like if you could do the odds over again
you would have two Knights versus only
one night right the three nights almost
gotten each other's way they were all
there were so many pieces over there on
the Kings side yeah exactly I mean for
sure um yeah it's yeah it would have
been better to have like not these three
Knights somehow got in the way but it
happens now when you did when you did
make this trade on e5 on move 20 and
then play Bishop d8 it still felt like
black black surely must still be better
here the bishop as you said is guarding
all the critical light squares but it
just became harder and harder to
coordinate the Knights and sort of use
that extra piece and and what was what
were your thoughts on maybe how you so
again I guess you've already said maybe
Bishop f5 early on instead of Bishop d6
would have been better perhaps playing
Bishop e6 instead of Bishop d7 I'll move
13 that would have been the big choice
Bishop e6 would have been a much better
decision than in the game is there any
other overall feeling you have like now
having played this particular material
it's have you ever played this one
before I know I well I think I might
have played it one time but I didn't get
a position like this I mean I've never
gotten good positions I'm getting great
positions today for some reason so it's
very pleasant but yeah I mean like
you're the one you're the one super game
I could ask that too because like I said
you played so many
these you've played a lot of different
odds but this three nights one is
definitely a little unique right no yeah
yeah yeah Bhishma sigh huh I move for
four yeah no but oh wow all right well I
mean overall I'm sitting here with the
rest of the the twitch chat and everyone
just served Bokova but going into the
last game I will say cuz I think it's
it's gonna be one of the most fun
versions of the material odds we've had
and so I'll say that part of the big
reason I was surprised that Komodo
repeated against you is because I was
under the impression we had set the
contempt to be at a very very high level
in the match for you so that we wouldn't
have those types of repeating draws so
I'm sure yeah I mean I guess I guess
evidently I thought it was much worse
than that endgame that's my guess yeah
so I mean I'm not really sure why but
it's hard for me to understand why I
would think it's much worse but I mean I
I guess that's just how things yeah well
interesting stuff so now as we head into
the final game everybody the nightmare
is gonna be something like you've never
seen before unless you saw her car was
previous man versus machine match but it
is it's going to lead to a lot of a lot
of fun and although not necessarily
theoretically relevant positions
certainly interesting interesting things
when it comes to trying to battle
against the computers thank you BJ h13
for subscribing for 10 months in a row
and all the other subs we've had while
hakarl has been in deep thought thank
you to everybody for your support today
all right there you go as you can see if
you just joined us Socorro is up 22 to
over all today so you've had you've
gotten some wins today I mean you feel
good about that right it feels good to
be Komodo regardless at the level it is
that's fair yeah I'm very unhappy with
the last two games I thought I got great
positions out of the opening of both so
alright well we're gonna we're gonna let
you take your one final break maybe get
you throw some water on your face you
got a nightmare ahead of you and you're
gonna have to play it like Lionel Richie
all night long if you're gonna have a
trance here against Komodo so we're
gonna let a carro take his last and
final break before the nightmare
position comes up all of you do the same
get yourself a snack and and we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
all right nightmare will commence soon
decision is the nightmare give you
nightmares or you haven't thought about
it since you lost played it I haven't
thought about it since I last played it
well it's looking weird to it yeah I'm
excited too especially with the the
Monte Carlo approach we'll see if that
changes anything about how it plays but
mm-hmm all right good luck sir
Thanks all right so here we go so Knight
f3 um I'll try to take something else or
it is wearing my pawns D 5 D for Knights
have nice look like they've got better
where do they better square is from okay
III C 3 D 3 I play D Phi D 4 C 5 he's
gonna just take the pawn flip side C 5
we'll just see if d5 opens the diag C 5
doesn't see five looks correct but d5
open it up
take stick probably he won't take but I
feel like you really need to open it
early I remember from last time I played
played this one a few times I did
against komodo or stock which whichever
engine it was that you need to open it
up if you got some sort of fixed
structural you got like efore like c4 c5
it was like e 4 and d3 then the Knights
have a lot of squares whereas here they
don't so I'm pretty happy with the first
two moves first three moves so far I
mean I'm gonna get both diagonals nicely
positioned with with an open file as
well so it's not it's I'm very happy
with this position as well just like the
last two games very happy with the first
couple of moves undoubtedly I'll be very
unhappy by the end as usual but maybe
this time that won't be the case
so it's thinking a lot here this is a
night this feels like the perfect first
couple of moves so this really feels
very nice simply be six orgy since I'm
not sure it matters so I'll play g6
first this looks like a very very
pleasant position to start with so let's
let's just see it's gonna be hard for
hard for white to because before is
possible to trying but I mean it's gonna
be very hard here without opening up too
much for white so I'll play a visual
cheat or no I'll play v6 protect protect
upon not that it matters but just get
both dying
real question is how am I gonna what am
I gonna sacrifice here 95 wow that's a
very bold trying to provoke me into
playing f6 I guess what does nighty make
sure there are no Forks nights 6 Queen
d7 I don't really understand what 95
does maybe f4 here I guess but f4 looks
very loose
93 okay so I could play f6 and kick the
night back and I think that will I'm
gonna I'm gonna put just like in the
previous couple of games you guys I'm
gonna play as principled as I can I mean
maybe he wants to go Knights e4 e5
Knight d5 or something weird I don't
really understand this very clearly I
mean he's got to go to c4 here cuz
otherwise Knight f3 or Knights I mean
actually is the computer moved upon or
able to move the C pawn it's a start I
guess but now do I want to go a five and
give them a chance to plop something on
d5 here's the first question if I do is
it a big deal or not that's I don't
think I want to give them the
opportunity to plot it somehow Knight d5
y e4 Knight f4 looks very suspect but
I'm going to play the play the logical
continuation then also here
tonight's are very poorly placed like
these nights especially have problems
getting into the game and there no there
no outpost for the Knights thus far at
least so this looks like a very good
position to be three now I could play e5
here then he's got Knight b5 is 95
really an issue ah I want to do it I'm
gonna not do it though I don't think ok
so I played Queen d7 what's his idea he
wants to go Knight g3 I'm worried about
if I was gonna go some night you 394 and
but I've got so many pawns here in the
center it's hardly that I can't do
something
okay let's go for it let's let's see
so as
Wow okay so I will castle probably he'll
put something on f2 in e4 but he's still
got no outpost it's worth noting like
White has these very the Knights are
fine but there are no pawns in the
center like if he this pawn to e4 and he
could plop something on d5 it would be
much better for white than this I felt
because the Knights don't really have
any squares I have too old to play
traditional Queen d7 probably work 88
next move although he is finding a way
to get all his Knights into the game
somehow
to a four so he wants to play a five
maybe do I care mmm do I care so he
wants to go a five or not really he's
just bluffing
like Queenie sex I think he's just
bluffing a five doesn't say a five it's
not actually creating a threat so and
also maybe now I'm trying to play f-5e
for as well if I can ever get in some
kind of break in the center and create
any sort of open file for my rooks
that'll be game over so clean sense
protects b6 but it also creates this
f-5e for maybe got five F for even a lot
of threats a ninety five so now I try to
jump a little bit he is trying to jump
now here I could chuck an exchange
already and maybe it makes sense to do
that might make sense to do that already
it's an interest
decision here whether I want to chuck it
or not I I think I'm I don't feel quite
ready to just like chuck everything so
I'm just gonna play Queen e7 keep it
simple
oh and now I just rise I just gave him
93 94 he's like starting to jump now
that might have been Queenie something
might be a mistake I probably should
have just played off 5 but I guess I can
also play rookie DX of 97 I've got
Bishop takes off 3 so sure enough VI is
trying to do some some weird stuff so
now I could play work 88 maybe 97 f5 and
just try to blast him
this has to be winning somehow so I
played 86 he's gonna go nighty or 95
probably yeah he's gonna go an ID 5 done
and then I've got all kinds there all
kinds of tricks ok so a 6 or I can play
a 696 b5 maybe
96b 598 5 bishop f3 yeah New York just
rook FD 894 them was a problem or is it
94f 596 me for okay I don't even know
what's going on here but I'm gonna play
48
Wow g-force so he gives okay so he's
trying to prevent f5 so f5 is really
critical then that's what I can gather
from this so maybe now I should play a
693 Queen c7 probably ninety three maybe
five ABA v 9p v e4 to blast it also
reasonable so 93 so now if b5 he has to
take and I'm 90 be v e4 FA for Bishop b4
[Music]
b5 takes a circuit one night CD one okay
let's open some files let's play more
principal just cuz for rooks you really
need these open files if you can get
them so any
takes otherwise I get be for with the UH
with the fork on the two nights on
see-through and ether so takes takes
probably he'll take with the C night and
then I'm counting on you for being my my
trump card here and it's also gooks now
I've got an open file too so this this
game is going according to plan so far
but I just realized on e4 takes takes
take C is Knight takes e5 or something
like Fe for brush 494 Queenie 495 Queen
East 7 his night-night a4 wow this is
weird
alright I'll go for it why not and of
course the more open the more open this
position becomes better my rooks become
- I suspect that I should be winning
already but I've I've played this before
and the computer is somehow very
resourceful that's putting the nights on
outpost and somehow protecting
everything so I'm not going to count my
count my eggs before they've hatched so
he does take and after Queen e7 what to
it what am I missing
wait wait actually Queen c6 wait Queen
c6 picks up wait no Queen C sex would be
for too many nights on the board Queen C
6 D for Bishop f8 looks good
or wait Queen 64 work a3 looks pretty
good too a queen e7 be for I guess is
his plan then work a4
Quincy 6b for Bishop f8d for orc takes a
a3 looks good this is crazy so Queenie 7
b 4f v GF 5 Queen h4 King d1 Bishop d4
maybe there's a d4
so d4 I think I'm gonna wait d 4f v
probably is what I'll do you know okay
so you plays b4 which kind of expected
and now I think we're okay for is that
my move also rook b8 to move to New York
ABA makes more sense
some point I have to play f5 or bish
page so I can just get rid of this
Bishop for this this night one of these
nights I think so d3 wow that feels like
a very loosening move now f5 or maybe
Bishop h6 or just fish baits X why not
feel like I've got a very nice position
here but whether I can convert it's a
whole different story
probably go rook c8 and rook takes c5 if
I can at some point king b1 Wow so maybe
rook seeds in order here ok let's try to
sack something let's try and clarify
this a little bit if possible because
you can't leave this night because in
this night hangs
tonight's e3 wait so now if I take yeah
I'm gonna sack for starters Oh weaponize
94 mmm and still looks like it should be
winning if he takes off his tank this
looks very good this is definitely
winning but I have to convert for a
change so let's see what makes f5 make
sense rookie 8 does not really make
sense may work eh yeah okay it's a move
rook to e8 force a Knight to d5 or I can
take no but if I take then he gets what
he wants he gets four Knights against
the Queen in a row and that's not really
what I want to allow so let's say so
Queen d4 maybe now the forks are mostly
gone which is a good thing there aren't
that many nights left so the so Forks
are more or less something I don't have
to worry about but his Knights are
getting very tangled here like his he's
holding on but somehow I need to I need
to break this break this King side yeah
that's the big question is how do I
break his King side so I think rook e8
makes sense if 95 I'll sack the rook
he's it's kind of hard for him to define
now he's got a lot of problems
so he does good he goes 95 ah in fact
that's a very good move because somehow
now he he boxed me again now I don't
have work d8 allows 97 maybe a 5 about 5
hero move the time for the hero play
mm-hmm rook da 97 King g7 Knight c3 and
there are some tricks looming maybe a
Bishop g5 is also move move that I like
five might be a threat doctor f5 was
probably our last move but okay I'll
retreat my queen to the open file so h3
I'll play prophylactically King g7 get
my King out of any 94 sorter tricks
d - walking into a pen but I can't take
advantage of or something
what Knight c7 rookie seven-night see
some night teeth it's gotta be a way to
win here
93 okay so I'm slowly starting to get
what I want so now I just need to find
the right way - lets see Queen jus one
maybe and again now with my King on g7
there so so there are no real tricks
here for white so this is 90 for Queen H
- probably well the night before coming
sure you can take it and put another
knight on e4 or something
94 h6 I'm holding the pons I think 94 h6
and looks like I'm holding the pons
so d 4 okay so he wait now he's gonna
try and push his pawn wants to try and
make a queen somehow this can't be
right though I mean my pawn has to be
fast here d6 could play rook b8 rookie 3
good rook b8 94 it doesn't look right
because I know in flogging it Forks
ain't 94 h5 maybe 94 probably so go 94
I'll play aged 695 and then back to e8
that's my plan
94 aged 695 oh sure I was getting he's
getting jumpy Queen g3 Knight e4 Queen
h2 96 kg 847
ha ha Knight f6 is a threat now and I
690 he's sure nice exchanger 796 takes
98 Queen b6 98 King out 798 King some
night he ate throw on a Chuck just to
cover Knight f6 candy 3 I can play aged
5 here maybe no the 96 so are all kinds
of little tricks here okay I can't take
on g4 I can't with my Brooke Queen f1
night work be 892 traps my queen somehow
yeah it's insane King III
ninety-two anyone don't have rookie
three truck qingxue - Chuck oh no is
this gonna be a draw - does he have some
king C - okay - king d3 oh I don't
believe this now if I move just for you
guys oh wait I've got Queen eh three
Chuck Queen h3 903 work a three wait
wait Queenie three kings c4 I'm still
getting freakin meeting on Knight f6 wow
this is unbelievable
unbelievable
ah well I'm still proud I'll say that
that was that was crazy it's it's a
ridiculous meaning that you'll never see
that meeting that again those three
nights they create this ridiculous
meeting that the constant threat for
those who were we're still asking
where's the mate the point is Hikaru if
the Queen ever leaves f6 you have this
you have this really really nasty Knight
f6 Queen DC - yeah like Queen e2 Knight
f6 key 907 crazy well what is your what
was your experience of of playing the
nightmare that it really felt like for a
while you were driving to position
toward toward open files toward open
diagonals but at a certain point the
Knights as you said they just got jumpy
it was just it was just crazy yeah I
mean I think probably somewhere around
move 30 somewhere around this point when
he put one comodo put the King on D -
walking into the pin okay I mean I maybe
there's some F no f5 doesn't work right
here there's probably some f5 I mean I
suspect also probably if you go back to
move 16 instead of yep instead of rook
FD 8 maybe no no not there sorry I mean
um after 95 Queen ISA yeah move 1593
here I suspect f5 was was the way to go
and that was one way or to play we're
actually rookie da was the other way
like rook ad 897 f5 Knight takes and
like efore or something got it okay I
mean I see some of the chats at
something
hello Aisha h4 at which position oh I
moved 35 I had Bishop h4 oh this is what
I missed this is winning this must be
winning yeah ah yeah because now you
know everything's collapsing yeah this
is this is probably winning I'm gonna
I'm gonna guess whoever made that
suggestion might have had an engine
running with them but I don't know maybe
I'm wrong either way Bishop h4 publish
page 4 yes yeah
yeah because now like I don't think
white can really coordinate very well
cuz just queen h2 Queen takes h3 is just
gonna be winning every two minutes and
your Bishop on h4 holds f6 and kind of
keeps everybody at bay right yeah this
this probably would have been winning
but I mean it's still still I wouldn't
say it's it's easy it's probably winning
but this there's still some technical
problems I'm guessing right Wow
well having in hindsight as we as we now
get to you know the match is over you
you won the match from the perspective
that you got 20/20 the overall score you
had twenty I don't even think that that
overall score is correct is it yeah I
guess it is yeah you had twenty and a
half to two and a half so yeah you know
not not a bad days work I guess but what
was your experience how would you
evaluate the overall did you notice a
difference in how the Monte Carlo
approaches these positions from from
previous material odds matches you've
had or does it feel like overall you're
just playing a beastly and I mean I
think actually based on the Monte Carlo
I got much better positions than you
probably should get is is my is my gut
feeling so I felt like in all the odds
matches I got great positions like I
didn't just get good positions I got
great yeah and so I think actually if
anything was in to my advantage um
I mean if anything I'm just unhappy I
didn't win them so I really felt like I
got I mean just got much better than I
was expecting even okay well this is
something that is is a huge topic of
conversation what are the right types of
odds we can apply to these games where
we're strong humans like yourself have a
chance and matches like this and what
would you say about the balance was
right
you've got good positions feels like
some that that you that you wish you had
back you would have won again but also
obviously the computer is still the
computer and makes very few blunders do
you feel like this is kind of the right
balance of where it even matches or what
would you change about this if you could
yeah I mean I think it's very close I
mean I think the moral the story is you
just can't you can't make any kind of
mistake really you make any even slight
mistake and suddenly like it's uh it's
like impossible to win I think that's
what it is
I mean I think the odds I got great
position so clearly the odds it's
possible to play as a human with these
odds I mean it's just it's extremely
hard to make no mistakes whatsoever I
mean that's the hardest hardest thing
just literally making zero mistakes and
I don't think anyone can do that which
is why computers are I mean you if we I
mean I was I did find in these
individual games but I guarantee if I
played this night odds like probably
more than two two games I'm sure that I
would I would lose quite badly because
it's just eventually I would just start
walking into ridiculous Forks everywhere
right well overall as we look for more
and more fun ways for computers and
humans to play what other types of
matches do you think would be
interesting in this format somebody
asked that question in twitch would you
consider a match of another strong human
paired with an engine like we've done
before sort of human ante and computer
teammate versus a Monte Carlo engine of
some kind or what are your thoughts on
on these matches I mean I only play huge
I mean I just like playing straight up
for the most part I mean I buy straight
actually I don't mean literally playing
blitz straight up because obviously
there's no point to that but I mean I
prefer these odds matches where you're
playing straight up as opposed to with
with the computer
say ok I I actually really like the
challenge of trying to to beat the
computer and I think that's always a
frustration what's up even in these
nightmarish positions this is a fun
challenge for you yeah because I'm
getting good positions I mean I I it's
if you can get the good positions that
it's hard to not own not enjoy it I mean
it's it's always fun trying to be a
computer it's obviously considering how
good they've become so so yeah I really
like I like these odds cool well as I
look for some some of the final
questions that fans if you have it while
we have Hikaru here feel free to ask
them and while we do as you as you just
mentioned playing blitz straight up I
can't let you go without putting you on
the spot regarding the next big event so
at some point here one of your one of
your children one of the many people
you've adopted in your lifetime Eric
Hanson popped into the chat and the
question comes up with the speed chess
championship getting set for this year
the the first event of its kind is
actually going to be the qualifier and
so as you look at this field of four
people let's let's have you play expert
you were very good at predicting the
Eagles would win the pro chess league so
if you look at your admirer young love
dick hammer
Lanier Dominguez Perez and Eric Hansen
who's the favorite in your eyes to win
in in the speech just knockout format oh
that's that's pretty easy Dominguez is
definitely the favorite I would say in
general Dominguez is the big favorite I
would put Meyer as sort of the Dark
Horse because I think he's extremely
capable of playing very well blitz
somehow it just doesn't seem to happen
when it when it matters most but he's
quite strong so I would say Dominguez
Meyer and and any Eric Eric I would say
also that has about the same chance as
as Meyer does and then young Ludwig who
I think his chances are close to zero
all right well for those who for those
who don't know the full field is
available you can go to speech just
championship calm but we got we have
some interesting and new unique faces
being added to the field this year
players like Wei Yi of course returning
players like Fabiano and MBO will also
be joining yourself at Caro but on that
note without Magnus in the field this
year you're clearly you have to be the
heavy favorite on paper you've made it
to the championship the final round both
yours to play Magnus so as you look at
the field everybody in their car yeah
Kunz coming back of course we just
mentioned MBL Fabiano who do you see as
potentially your the biggest threat to
you in in this year's speeches
championship um you know I think the I
would say the same thing that I would
say about regular chess and I felt us
for a while now and that I feel that the
the only person there there are two of
us who I think when we play our absolute
best we're capable of playing very close
to the same level as Magnus and and I
would say that's myself and Sergei
cardiac and so I think Sergei definitely
would be the the biggest threat to
myself I mean I think we played a very
tight match in semi finals last year and
I mean based on all the matches I play
he he would be the other person
that I would say has I would say we're
probably even favorites I wouldn't even
put myself as a heavy heavy favorite
over him well obviously we saw surrogate
just played well along with yourself in
lovin so yeah I think that's definitely
a matchup a lot of people are will be
looking forward we both messed up we
both messed up one game in the end the
event more or less and that's the
difference between either of us winning
the event right but the summers not over
on to Paris right and best of luck to
you so you said to your fans those of
those of you who asked in the twitch
chat when it's a car we're gonna get
back to streaming at some point after
the Paris leg of the GCT is when you
think you're you're gonna have an active
twitch channel so maybe for them I guess
I would say pretty confidently sometime
right around July 2nd probably not the
first because of course up north there
is something called Canada Day on the
first but but up but probably on July
2nd that would be my guess Canada days
when you when you take Eric out for a
walk to the park maybe I mean Eric's
like living in Montreux you know those
guys want to separate from Canada so I'm
not so sure that they uh they they they
would be happy about that right well
either way your car oh this has been
amazing remind everybody the next big
event to mark your calendars for hey
Cara Nakamura of course getting back to
streaming on his own twitch.tv /g mikaru
and then of course you heard it here as
Hikaru predicted Dominguez Perez and
Georg Meyer he puts there as the
favorites so tune in yeah I mean I'll
put it this way I would say the the odds
I would put it at on I would say it's 55
yeah I'll go fifty five percent for
Dominguez and then um I'll go with 20 20
percent for both Eric and and Georg and
then five percent for him all right well
there you go tune in on June 26th Grand
Master Robert Hess and I will have the
call a call hey Cara will be I guess
you'll still be in Paris or on your way
home actually at that time well this has
been awesome thank you hikaru I'm uh
this has been this has been a blast I
hope you enjoyed it as much as as much
as we did because it would be much nicer
pride won one of those stupid yams but
yeah I enjoyed it yeah other than that
game the game twenty I mean it you were
in control of every game
really and yeah but I mean from what
from what I was told apparently is
playing at full strength in game 20 so
it wasn't actually 24:49 and what we
this I just thought of this but on that
note I mean what would you say is the
best way for people to use computers in
their training to get better I mean I
would you say that playing against
computers like this is is kind of good
as training to stay sharp since they are
so ruthless at punishing blunders really
forces you to be tactically on your game
or or how would you recommend using yeah
I mean I think if you can sort of resign
yourself to accepting the fact that
you're gonna make blunders and you can
and you can you're okay with that and
you're just you're just trying to play
consistently well of course you can't
play perfectly but if you're just trying
to play reasonably well then then I
think playing playing maybe not straight
up from the start of the game but just
you know certain sorts of positions just
playing around with computer I think
there certainly are big benefits to that
all right all right well we wish you the
best of luck in Paris man the the fans
can't wait to see you back on Twitch and
this has been a blast so I'm gonna I'm
gonna say say goodbye go have a good
night there and we will we'll see you
we'll see you back on Twitch and early
July thanks bye alright bye you guys
[Music]